Shut up. >> You're telling me to shut up because I'm telling
you something real. Do you understand that you are deserves handcuffing?
They are handcuffing both Legacy and Princess. Even if it's illegal,
are you really arresting them over this? That's crazy. I feel
like this could be that they're so done with this house, so done
sending people here. They're just like, "If you're going to around
and waste our time, you're going to start going to jail." >> So,
most of us have been here quite a bit. We know y'all stream,
right? We
walks out. You getting
>> Who's the black dude? Cuz he filmed
>> We got this. And then I think there's going to be some
drama with like Darius's old roommates and the squeeze guy. I
think we're going to check that out in a little bit as well.
>> Remove the m the mystery reading music.
>> Oh, sure. Sure. Yeah. >> Some interesting stuff.
>> Wait, what happened with Darius's roommates? Uh they're
just >> roommates. The old ones are >> squeeze the
kid who looks really young. >> Uh went back and he is fighting
with process and legacy because he didn't pay his rent for the
last month or something. And basically he left a GPU there. So
they're holding his GPU and telling him to off like give us our
rent and we'll give you your back. No. >> Is that >> that's
illegal? >> Oh. Uh oh. So I think that's what's happening.
So I've got some clips and I might go to it in a little bit.
I can send some clips, but I think there'll be something to >> I
actually don't know if that's illegal. I just like looked at
him dead in the face like I was so confident. >> You said
it like you were serious. >> Okay, you get that. >> Nobody
cares. >> You're trying to skirt your responsibility. No,
nobody cares. Sorry. Everybody here cares. >> I wish you
would try something. >> Every single person in this house
cares. >> I wish you would try something right now. I wish
you would. >> What do you mean try something? You mean
you mean hit a child? >> If you have some If you have such
a >> I'm not going to hit a child. >> Do something
about if you
so why do you >> guys trying to press
legacy of all people so we'd have to go back and we could watch
through this a little bit um we're going to be playing catchup
a little bit but hey >> talking and not doing anything
about it >> okay
that pay renting we are civil humans that pay rent >> we
are grown men that pay rent
we pay rent >> w payers any rent payers in the chat not
for long given where the economy is going but hey we Got we got
some rent payers in here. Okay, we got this one. We've got one
other one.
Okay, this that's that one. >> Oh my god. Really? Took
over? I'm going to look into that. The onion. >> This is
all normal. >> This is this normal.
>> Yes, it is. Because when you [__] Why do
you keep Why do you keep raising your >> Because I hate
you. >> Because with every
I hate you.
>> Oh, it's like a legacy. Legacy's going the off. Hold
on. Okay, so I think Legacy's technically in the wrong here,
but it does sound like he hates this guy. Shocking. All right.
Um, we've got this one. I've got one more clip,
but because time and time again take advantage of my friends
that are nice to you and treat you like a decent person when
they probably shouldn't. You're telling me to shut up because
I'm telling you something real. Do you understand that? You are
taking fighting right here. >> The deed has been done,
sir. I hope you learn to be a good friend one day to someone.
I really hope so. Okay. I didn't hate you, but I absolutely do
hate you now. >> All right. Well, I mean, just so you know,
I don't hold a grudge against you. All right. There we go. >> Okay.
I hold a grudge against you. >> Okay. Keep holding it.
>> Men can't be hoed, buddy. >> I straight up hate
you, bro. You love to see it. Uh, let's see. We're hour 13 in.
I'm going to switch over to his actual VOD so that we don't get
cut off by happening. The guy that was driving in the car with
sleeves, right? >> What is that about?
>> He looks like the type of person to get expelled from
college. >> Oh, look. They put I owe $520 on his window
for his car. And they they appear to have >> What was this?
Plastic wrap. They appear to have plastic wrapped his car for
him. >> That you the Zeus treatment, didn't
>> Who's Squeeze again? Squeeze is just somebody who used
to live in the Darius house. He's like the young looking guy
right here. He hit on that drunk girl. You remember the guy who
looked like he was going to rape that drunk girl? That
>> That drunk I remember him as the person that Adriana
Lee's mom was trying to get >> Yeah. He was also hitting
on Adrian Lee's mom. Yep. Yeah. All of these things. All of the
above. >> He wanted me to do a lot more. >> Good
thing he didn't. >> You're good to go. >> A good
thing >> cuz that's not
allowed by him. >> Oh, wait.
>> Okay. So, they his car a little bit. >> Okay.
And keep holding it.
>> Suitcase along >> with all your personal belongings
and >> All right. >> And then um Hayden made sure
to give you back your food. >> Oh, did he?
>> Wonderful. I actually have been looking for this. You
know, it's >> it's your science experiment. He knows how
much you want your science. >> This is like uh the most
passive aggressive roommate drama. They're like, "Hey, remember
that bag of that that box of strawberries you left rotting in
the fridge? You piece of [__] >> Here it is.
We saved it for you cuz you
>> Yeah. Goodness. >> Yeah, I can do a lot with this.
>> So, keep it. Don't throw it away. >> Cool. All
right. I know these anything these trash bags are definitely
worse.
>> That just gave me memories. Do you remember that time
where Rei was on stream and he's like, "Oh [__] I
missed trash day
like they were all supposed to take their trash." Like Rey keeps
his trash bags in his room.
He has like his own trash bag situ. I don't know why, but that
like lives in my head rentree. >> Oh, that like he just
doesn't want to interact with the rest of the house and he keeps
that space clean. >> The whole house I think has their
separate track because he couldn't fit his trash thing in the
trash bin.
Everyone put their trash out there, but they didn't bring the
trash forward, so there's no space for his, so he just had to
keep it in his room.
I don't remember that. But that sounds
Sounds horrible. >> Rei doesn't live like that now, so
we're happy. We're happy for him. >> He's doing better
now. He's doing better >> and then that's pretty much it.
>> I mean, I didn't really have that much stuff. I mean,
I I >> You have nothing here. >> Oh, that it's from
>> my my my thing, bro. Seriously, this is >> We
were. >> No. Oh, that's ridiculous.
That's >> Here we go. This is the setup. After he goes
upstairs, >> he's about to find out what city we're >> And
they go and start arguing. >> What are you saying?
>> What is that supposed to mean, man?
>> Someone else's room. >> Prawn. Excuse me, man.
>> Trying to enter his doicile.
>> Prawn, I'm to the to your right. I'm to your right.
>> Excuse me, Prawn. >> Through the door.
>> Do Can I come in? >> Nobody's behind. Squeeze.
Just so you >> dude. I can't hear. >> Do not to the
right.
>> Going out. >> My [__] connector. >> Ron,
can I I I need my uh property back, man. Uh it's mine and I'
I'd like to have it. >> I thought we would hold on to it.
>> I know you want to hold on to it, but I don't want you
to do that.
>> Um what Bronn needs to say here is I don't know where
your is, but maybe I could remember if you paid your rent. He
needs to say he needs to not say I'm going to hold on to it.
Okay, on camera process. I'm just saying you want to actually
break the law here, you need to do it better. This is not great.
Okay, you're not breaking the law well right >> I don't
know. Prawn look like the type of guy who might have fun a couple
nights in jail.
>> Fing squeeze made this guy house you all lame for kicking.
>> I'll pay you back regardless. I just want my my GPU
back, man. >> I said you betrayed my trust so much
>> that I don't trust you anymore. It's like I need kind
of some way to guarantee I'm going to have that. If like a piece
of collateral
is like a fair way to do that. >> I mean, you're not wrong,
but I still want it back. So, >> you'll get it back when
I get my rent. >> No, I mean, I want it back now. >> I
want my rent right now. But >> Well, I'll give it to you
when I'll uh
>> when I get paid cuz I physically don't have the money.
>> I'll give you your graphics card when he
Uh gets his money back. >> Well, there's a difference.
This what he's doing is not lawful. All right. So, >> you're
you're staying here without paying rent. What you're doing is
>> Bro, I don't have to stay here. Okay. I just want my
stuff back. I will pay you. >> He gives you the card back.
Will you leave tonight?
>> I mean, yeah. >> If you if you want me to.
>> That's on the table. Offer's on the >> I'll still
pay you. >> Well, he said he wants to leave the house tonight.
>> Thank you. I can't face him. >> I mean, the thing
is, if he leaves with all of his stuff, he's a [__]
garbage human being. Snake piece of [__] So, he's
not going to give anybody. >> Listen, don't talk to me
that way, man. Cuz I'm not going to take that
>> I mean, I No, I I think this literally just describes
everybody who's like a Austin kick IRL streamer, unfortunately.
Like, that's probably just accurate from Legacy, whereas I put
on the Burger King thing because we're doing uh we're doing CX
adjacent content now, and if I have a woman on screen, we'll
never get viewers. Okay, so I've just switched over to my own
avatar. That's it. That's how it is. any other call disgusting
names. Don't talk to me that way. >> I am calling you arguing
with you. And if you will pay you >> I'm a man of my word.
I don't have money right now and I will give it to you when I
have it. So >> you've like said that 20 times. >> Okay.
Well, I mean uh >> at what point do I tr do I stop trusting
>> I think
>> he wants his graphics carded so he can like leave >> probably
like a second time. >> Like you deserve it at this point.
Uh, I mean, I don't know, dude. This guy, this guy definitely
makes enough money that he could just pay his rent. Like, the
fact that he's just not paying his rent is weird. Like, I can
see he's got 1,000 viewers right now. >> You don't mean
prawn, right? You're
>> and that's going to fall
>> because you like people over whether it's friendships
or >> Listen, I'm not talking to you, man. What do you
not understand? >> I get to talk to you. You owe me just
the same amount of money as you owe him. I'm on the lease. I'm
on the hook for this [__] I want every single utility
that you're not paying for. >> Okay, that's fine. >> You
get that? You understand that? Are we straight? >> That's
fine. >> Okay, we straight. >> You know, I don't
really care about your little pressing. >> No. Okay. My
little present. >> It doesn't offend me, dude. It's not
about offending you. It's about making you like like understand
and like having some of this sink in because it's clearly not
sinking in for you. >> You have to understand. >> It
clearly did sink in. No, you're just saying I'm sorry. Maybe
I'll get it back to you. Like I'll get back.
Sat around doing dick all for the past four weeks. in disrespect
screaming. You get paid hourly to scream
for the third time. I'm not talking to >> But it sounds
like you are because you keep coming back to me and you keep
talking to me again and again. So you want to
do want to talk. >> Are you done? >> Yeah, I'm done,
boy. Go ahead.
>> I just want my boy. >> I'm done, boy. I'm done,
boy. >> thing back. I I guarantee you I will pay you back.
Like we can make an agreement or something. We already made an
>> Like paying utilities, we already made an agreement.
Stop. You need to cut >> bro. Shut the hell up. What is
your >> Cut through to him. >> I'm not talking to
you. >> Don't just say I will. I will. I will because you
say that. >> Bro, I'm telling you, I'm not talking to you.
Let me back. Back him up. Cuz also like you did have the money.
Like literally a month ago, you paid for like a hotel for $200
instead of paying me my >> All right. Well, that's my my
fault. I have a question. Squeeze. Did you come here on your
last dime? >> When? here to Austin. >> I mean, I
came here to get my stuff. >> But you But did you come
here on your last dime? >> Uh, what does that mean? >> Are
you like that flight ticket and now you have nothing?
>> I don't have much. No, >> you don't have much.
>> What is much?
>> It's not. >> I've noticed I noticed that nobody
here. Okay. Out of Chicken Andy who makes a lot of money. Adriano
makes pretty good money. They're not They're not exactly like
falling over to go, "Oh, I trust Squeeze. I trust Squeeze. Totally.
I totally trust Squeeze and he'll pay me back. So, Squeeze, I'll
lend you the money. Not a single person here is willing to trust
this. >> Is that dude bravely wearing all white Chicken
Andy?
>> I wouldn't wear white. Not just in this house, but around
any of these people. >> Uh, it's literally like chicken
Andy is as gross as any of these people. Okay. >> How does
it stay white? >> It doesn't. >> That's like probably
something he bought >> How much? >> What is not much?
>> It's a chicken soup. I'm not going to get into the specifics,
but I mean
>> to be honest, cuz I think all these people here >> Oh,
look out for you. >> No, I don't think so. >> And
we're upset. How >> Bro, I understand. Listen, three of
>> My uh I mean, I'm the new one here.
>> Um what do you what do you what are you at right now?
What's your uh what's your net worth? You know, like >> Well,
I'm not going to discuss that. >> Afford a hotel if you
can you afford a flight home, you grab your stuff, can you afford
a gas and leave? >> I can afford certain things. I'm telling
the problem that I can't >> think like
I think it would make everybody feel a lot less better if we
could just see your checkings and savings. I'll show you my checkings
and savings. >> I don't give a [__] about >> Okay,
that's weird. I think we should just look at your bank account.
Can we just look at your bank account? >> I don't trust
a that's just willing to pull out his. Why? >> Yeah, it's
just bizarre. Legacy is like a hed he's got like a not a hedge
fund. He's got like a trust fund. He's like a He's like His parents
are rich as Yeah, his parents are rich as [__] So,
I don't know. Maybe he's just going to >> Okay. So, we
give a [__] about yours because you have to pay us.
>> Clearly, you do. >> Do you understand that? >> Listen,
don't raise because No, because this whole >> Don't raise
your voice at me. >> Yeah, I understand that. Yeah, I >> Don't
raise your voice at me, buddy. >> I understand that. I'm
sorry. I'm going to pay you guys back. That's what you've been
saying to Darius Prawn, all of us for the past 3 months, >> bro.
You really You really need to develop a hobby. >> You need
to develop a hobby. This is my hobby. Thank you very much. This
is literally my hobby. You need to literally learn a skill and
do something else with your life. You need to do something else
with your life cuz clearly it's not working out for you. >> Clearly,
what you're doing with your life is not working out. It's definitely
working out my life. I pay all of my bills before anybody else.
I'm the most I don't care about your bills. I pay on the 27th.
You pay on the 20
month. Do you understand that? >> News flash. We don't
care.
You're still pointing the camera at me. So clearly >> I
am because I'm literally >> Legacy kind of popping off.
Legacy is actually kind of popping off here. Okay. Legacy sometimes
when he gets mad, a little cringe, a little drunk. >> He's
mostly sober and he's actually he's making money right now. >> So
talk to Brun and actually something out. Don't say I'm sorry.
Yeah, I know what I did. But like >> Although I will say
they're technically breaking the law probably almost certainly
by just keeping this guy's [__] instead of when when
he's not paying his rent. So I I don't know how this is going
to go if the cops get caught.
You are an actual >> Nobody wants to hear it, dude. Literally,
nobody wants they want to hear a solution. They don't want to
hear an apology for the problem. We get that you're sorry. >> I'm
trying to make a solution, dumbass. I'm trying to make a solution.
I'm trying to make a solution, dumbass. >> Then say it.
Go ahead. Please
me holding on to the ground. >> Bro, you can't just take
my stuff and just hold on to it hostage. That's not how life
works, bro. >> That's actually what they do at like storage
units when you don't pay. They >> Bro, you that's not the
law. What are you saying? >> That is the law. >> That
is the law actually. Yeah, that is. >> That is something
different.
>> You probably sign a contract saying all the property
there is forfeit to them if you can't pay them, right? >> You
sign a explicitly different contract with a storage unit. >> Sign
a contract and they have to wait a period of time before they
can just do whatever they want with it. >> Yeah, that makes
sense. >> It's a lean. >> Okay. Well, there's no
such thing. >> I think we would be well within our >> There's
no such thing. There's no such thing right now. >> Wait.
I feel like because you're not paying rent to us, we might actually
have grounds to put a lean on his car. >> We could >> like
unironically.
>> Yeah, dude. I think we could
I don't want to come to that. >> Yeah, that's definitely
not true, but um thank you very much for that. >> Test
that theory.
>> I know the law more than anyone. >> Um well, listen,
>> I know the law more than Did Adriana Ali just say that?
She knows the law more than anyone. >> But you went to
a YouTuber to fix your >> You went to a YouTuber to fix
your finances. As far as I know,
does she I don't know if anybody won a lawsuit against Msk. I
think she was one of them. No, I was just saying there might
be some people who know the law better.
Not to say anything about lawsuit should have gone. >> Wait,
what do you mean? >> I believe Adriana tried to sue Miss
Kip. No. And >> did she not win? >> I don't think
so. No, I'm pretty sure that got dismissed. >> Do you think
But hold on. We're
hiring a lawyer
to file a suit does not mean you know anything about the law.
>> Yeah, but that's what I'm saying. She doesn't know about
the law. >> Is that where you think she's pulling the confidence
from? >> I think she talked to a lawyer once. >> Yeah,
I talked to a lawyer once. >> Yes. Unironically, I think
that's what it is. I think she talked to a lawyer. >> I'm
willing to I'm willing Hold up. >> One of us. >> No.
No. Goon, I haven't. So there that's bull. I have not Goon. That's
bull. Um, >> you said you were off a bunch on the mattress
when we just want to know how much is the graph graphics card
worth. >> doesn't matter how much it's worth. It's mine,
man. So, how come he can just take >> It's his It's the
lean, dude. >> That's That's not a thing right now. That's
That doesn't exist. >> It was in the contract. >> No,
it was There was no contract. I never signed. >> Chicken
Andy is just like It's in your lease, dude. Why would Chicken
Andy have seen the lease? >> Verbal contracts. You know
what's funny? We couldn't Zeus from this house >> because
we had a verbal contract with him. And in the state of Texas,
a verbal contract holds up. So, we did have a verbal contract
with you. Were you >> you're trying to scare me right now?
>> If I don't take So, are you guys graphics card? You
told it to us. >> You both are trying to scare me right
>> Scare. Not scam. Scare. >> Graphics card. >> W
graphics card. Hey, you know what? >> I'm about to generate
so many images of
>> I don't want to have a problem with your security. That's
$100. Like, fine. Good. I won't take that. I just want $300.
That's all I'm asking for. I'm already >> I'm willing to
give it to you when I get paid, man. >> Just get paid,
man. I'll give you your credit card. >> That's not how
it works. >> Just grind up for like a week. >> Just
because I didn't pay you doesn't mean I I Dude doesn't mean you
can take my property, man. That's not how life works. Sorry.
>> My property. >> Exactly how it was in the the
house of the owner of the house. >> Right. And I'm willing
to leave right now. And I'm willing to take my stuff and leave.
>> You're taking my money on my wall. >> Just tip
$2.
Please don't give any money to these white trash subhumans. >> Is
that actually you? >> I wonder if that's actually anyways.
Man, I'm I don't want to like put this any further probably.
>> If you can't trust me, if I if I have to trust you to
give you your money, why can't you trust me to give you a gravity
card back? >> It's not about trust. I just I want it right
now. >> Well, it is about trust for me. >> Cuz it's
mine. I don't want somebody else to have it. >> I I trust
you. >> You know what was mine? The dishes.
>> Okay. And I'm willing to to compensate
used in my bathroom. By the way, I told >> I'm willing
to compensate for that. I'm willing to compensate for that. >> He's
not going to compensate. >> Yes, I will >> compensate
whatever the [__] you said. He's not going to >> anything
else worth worth another 30 bucks. I'll take a different object,
but I think that's a piece of CL. >> Bro, you can't take
anything. I told you I'm going to like What? That's not What
are you even saying? >> Collab. I don't trust you. >> Wait.
Sorry. By the way, by the way,
>> do you want to hire a lawyer? >> I don't need
a lawyer. >> It's not criminal. It's civil. It's a $300
graphic. Not overnight. >> You think I don't know that?
>> Okay. You going to hire a lawyer? >> Bro, you
don't even know the Shut the >> You going to hire a lawyer?
>> You going to see what happens? >> Why do you keep
on yapping?
>> No, because I know what's going on. >> Just shut
the hell up. >> Hold on. Are we going to live? I might
have to switch over to live. Give me a
>> there's some crazy [__] happening on the
live right now. Okay, >> might be annoying. >> We
got We got to skip forward. Okay, we got to skip forward. There's
some crazy
He went out. Okay, but he keeps >> I might stay here. Who
knows? Cuz
oh god,
>> there's no way. There's no way this happened, right?
This 251. Oh well, it's totally fake then. >> So it's And
then homeboy, skip forward a little bit. If you put on paper
that you're choosing to pursue charges against these two individuals
>> and it shows that that's perjury, meaning that that
was a stunt that you have online or that that was agreed upon
or any evidence that debunks what you're saying, that is a charge
as well and you will face that. >> Okay. I can tell you
officer that it >> that's just letting you know. It's it's
I'm not trying to scare you. I'm letting you know though with
the digital age and you guys doing all your streams and Twitches
and things like that, if it comes up in court that they were
you guys have a ruse and you're doing an online thing, >> then
you may charges too. >> Just letting you know. >> You're
doing this for content. >> I can guarantee you that I >> take
pictures real quick. Okay.
>> Hey. Um, >> hey sir. Can I talk to you? >> I
can I can guarantee you that this was definitely not skate or
anything like that. I I came here off a flight. I can show you
the flight information. I just wanted to grab my stuff simply
and leave >> and I came here and my items were gone. >> Well,
that saw everybody when they charges just the consequence of
a false. >> Okay. Well, >> I mean, it's on video.
They did it without my consent and I didn't, you know, want to
do it. I didn't agree to it. I didn't want anybody to take my
stuff. I mean, I've been dealing with this for the past, you
know.
>> the cops are done with this house. >> They are
so done with this house off of our off of our radar. >> Let's
grab it. Let's Is this help? Hold
>> This is like the >> All right. Thank you, officers.
>> I want to see what this is. Okay, I got sent a screen
cap. If this screen cap is
>> some crazy [__] about to happen that I did
not expect out of this. Okay, >> but it might be the solution.
>> There's Legacy coming out.
>> Jesus Christ.
I went through handcuffing. They are handcuffing both Legacy
and Princess. >> Wait, I was right when I said that's illegal.
Well, even if it's illegal, are you really arresting them over
this? That's crazy. I feel like this could be that they're so
done with this house, so done sending people here, they're just
like, "Whatever. Whoever's the most wrong, we're arresting them.
We're going to actually start making these people go to jail
and like sit overnight cuz if you're going to around and waste
our time, you're going to start going to
>> I No. No. My listen,
I have seen when I was younger, I saw somebody steal a candy
bar and makeup from a CVS. They got put in the back of a cop
car. >> Yeah. Not shocking. >> Stealing. You have
to you have to put them in.
>> Uh there's definitely there's definitely things where
you don't have to put them >> No, you have to fingerprint
them. You have to process them. This isn't civil. You called
the police. This is criminal now. You called the police and you
said that your property is being held
and they're stealing from you. This is a criminal thing now.
This is not civil.
>> Maybe. I think the problem for them is they've admitted
that they have the property. Usually it's like, "Oh, I don't
have that." Right. But they have the property. >> Jesus
Christ. This is what he deserves. I want you to >> So long
as they I'm sure the cops went in, they're like, "Yeah, I'm holding
this or whatever." And okay, did you prevent him from taking
it so he could leave? They're gonna have to say yes for so many
hours.
Bam.
>> He took my graphics card. It's on video. >> So,
he says it's on video. What's the chicken Andy clip we got with
the stolen GPU? Hold on. Hold on.
>> Do we put the banana in there? >> Oh, I think
we did put the banana in >> Oh, this is a clip from a while
ago, but this is definitely a different day. >> That's
nice. >> Yeah, you can sell that. I think >> found
his GPU. So, they're they're going through his looking take his
[__] Oh, >> that's trespassing.
>> It's so stupid all of this on camera. Why would the
would you put this on camera? You were >> Wait, trespassing
isn't the word for it. The the who did this with Ashley Biden's
journals, right? She was no longer renting that room. >> Yeah.
I don't And then she moved out. >> Probably just theft
or something. >> They rifled through her things and Yeah.
They they get you. >> Yeah. Yeah. It's
close. And it's not like it was laying around. It's just It's
literally just in his like it's in his bag that's closed and
there's a recording of you all opening the bag and taking it
out. >> The [__] are you trying to do? Jesus.
>> Okay. Well, now they're in cuffs. I still don't know
if they're going to get arrested. I feel like I feel like I would
expect somehow them to get out of this, but we'll see. >> Oh,
they don't get arrested.
>> I'm saying they're getting put in the car, but what's
going to happen? >> Yeah. I mean, I guess I'm going in
the
>> Sandals or something? >> I don't think they're
probably going to get booked and then they tell them the arraignment
date. >> Hey, man. What time did this happen at? >> Um,
well, this was while I was on a >> Okay. So, it was around
like
>> I can't tell you the exact time, but it was in the afternoon
for sure. >> Um, but I can go back in the clips and investigate
a little bit more, but I don't know if that's y'all's job,
>> No, I mean, I could probably just pull up the clip and
see. >> Okay. It's it's all on kick.com. That's where we
uh for sure. >> Sure. But what was your uh name, >> Uh
the Masters, badge number 487.
>> Let me check if I got a business card. Dude, what the
[__] >> I would like >> This is like
the most forthcoming cop I've ever Usually cops are just like
about this when you ask them. This cop's just like, "Nope, this
is me. This is my badge number. I'll see if I got a card for
you." >> No, you have to. >> Well, you have to, but
a lot of cops are like, "Why do you ask?" >> Know how?
>> Not in the States. No. >> Okay. I've definitely
watched them do it on multiple kick streams where they're like, "Why
do you need to know that?" But uh >> Really? Yep. I could
like communicate
>> like you you aren't supposed to. It's literally illegal
in a whole bunch of places. But cops always say, "Wait, why do
you want to ask?" They always get defensive. And then if you
press them, they tell you. >> I've never seen this. >> The
case >> the opposite.
>> Okay. I've seen it on multiple streams where they're
like, "What are you asking >> Right. They always like clarify.
They always do like this little offiscation thing. But it might
be a little >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Talk about it and get
more information on it. >> Got you. Me and Darius.
>> Oh, it might depend on the situation.
>> Oh, maybe if you're watching videos >> or channels
that are just showing you bad cops. >> I literally The
only people I watch break the law are this crew of people. >> No,
no. I mean like other YouTube channels. Like if you're if you're
referencing, oh, I always see cops do this thing. You you might
be seeing the small percentage of cops who are
going against their training. >> Sure. It's upstairs
uh on my desk right below my middle.
>> Uh here's my business card. Has my name, badge number,
uh has the >> Oh, man. The thing that I'm kind of excited
to go back and check on at some point here is I wonder if the
cops when they first got there, I wonder if they already know
if they're like, "Oh, this address again. We're fuck." I wonder
if they come in with like attitude right off the bat, right?
just like these
again and they're just like super short. I do want to see what
it's like when they first come in. We'll go back to it in just
a second. I just want to go to the time
>> and uh and legacy get arrested. >> Especially
because there are multiple people related to the house linked
to the house with lawsuits open.
>> Criminal charges open. >> Now those people aren't
even doing those people aren't even doing the content anymore.
Right. Zena's not doing this content. Darius isn't doing this
content, but somehow this house is still being a problem.
>> Okay, cool. I appreciate it. >> Yep. Pretty much
any officer should be able to answer your questions. Um >> so
I don't have to directly contact you. I can contact anyone else.
>> Yeah, they should be able to pull up the report. Um
this is my Friday, so don't call me tomorrow. I'm not going to
>> Got it. >> Dena absolutely has been on Action
Man stream a whole bunch of times and she's posted that she's
getting her channel back soon. So if you guys think he she's
not going to be doing content, you're out of your mind. Nemo,
you're saying some right now that you're gonna look for in like
three weeks or three to eight weeks. 4 to 8 weeks. Okay.
>> What else? I mean, basically after this, right, I mean,
you're most likely not even have to show up in court or anything.
Most of it's most stuff's
>> So you I mean, you might not even hear back from us.
Most likely not going to. Got it. >> Because it's all handled
courtside. I don't even know if maybe an attorney will contact
you. kind of. >> So, it's all stuff that we don't deal
with. Um, what else? >> I just appreciate your help and
you know, I >> I know that this happened while I was away.
I mean, I could show you the itineraries of the flights and everything.
You know, my goal coming >> Yeah, I don't need the itinerary.
I mean, you could have gone to Walmart, bro, and come back in
your trip, >> right? Um, like I said, my goal coming here
was just grab my stuff and leave. I don't want to live here anymore.
Moving out of this house, lived here for a couple months now.
>> Yeah, that's the that's the rough thing, guys, is uh
like he wasn't served with any formal notice that he was kicked
out and they just grabbed his and they got the clip of them grabbing
his >> He's not my friend. I don't >> I got you.
>> If you if you do decide to change your mind on pursuing
charges, you don't contact us. You contact the district attorney's
office. >> We don't we don't do the whole >> Can
you repeat that one more time? If if I don't >> So if you
do decide like let's say
>> You're like, "Ah, I actually don't want to pursue charges
anymore." >> Um contact the Travis County District Attorney's
Office. >> They're going to want to know the case number,
whatever. Like, I don't want to pursue charges on these guys
anymore. >> Dude, I don't know. Like it's so rough that
they go and they I could see how you almost might think this
is scripted because they went they stole his on camera and then
they kept saying on camera to him, "Yeah, we stole your [__]
and you'll get it back when you pay rent." And then he calls
the cops and he doesn't have his back like until the cops get
there. Like at some point you're just breaking the law openly,
dude. And I I'm guessing I'm guessing how this normally goes
if you're not streamers. This probably normally goes like, "Listen,
go get his give it back to him. We'll walk away." But given it's
this house again, it's like, "Hey, you took his.
You're going in." >> How do the neighbors deal with this?
Cuz this is a really big house. The people around you aren't
in streamer houses. Those are those are big houses with probably
like full families and stuff like that. >> Could be. Yeah.
>> I'd want these people the out of my >> Yeah. Everyone
want them. >> Um we don't go in to attorneys. the way that
I see them mow their lawn. >> That's not a thing. >> Okay.
So, it's it's me. It's on me now. >> Gave them a chance
to do that. There's no way. >> Oh, I'm almost just going
to go back to when the cops get there. >> Oh my god. Did
they do the thing where no
verbal contract?
>> Yeah. I saw Prawn and Darius getting arrested. I feel
like we go back right here. Hold on. I'll uh >> on the
state. The state is not pressing charges, are they? >> Correct.
Okay. Got it. >> You're the one pursuing charges. If you
want to stop between charges, you have to contact the district
attorney's office cuz once we >> I want to I Yeah, I do
want to go back. Give me a second. I'm going to go back to where
the cops actually get there. >> Cops arrive at 2 hours
and 34 minutes. 2 >> Why is the cop giving
>> Didn't he say Didn't the cop say if he doesn't want
He just doesn't want to get called again. Yeah, he just doesn't
want to get called again.
in that room downstairs and they moved it out. Okay. But you
did something with >> Look at Look at your extra room,
man. Okay, somebody this desk >> I don't, dude. It's fine.
All right, >> this desk, bro. Look at this. >> Okay,
you're rich. >> Wait, is chicken >> good, man? Good
for you. Holy [__]
>> like what? >> It goes up, too, >> bro. Just
give me my You're keep
>> Chicken Andy sitting here like, "Look, bro. Look, it
goes up. There we go. Cops have arrived.
>> Come down here. We just need to talk real quick." >> Hello
there.
>> Sweet chicken. We've not kept up with their house and
we should have.
>> So, who called? >> Say Darius. You mean Legacy?
I must have Darius.
So, if you guys bear with me here, I'd like to not repeat myself
so I can get everybody's attention and be on the same page. Okay.
>> Although, if I said Darius and Legacy, I might have
been referring to the clip where they pull his view out because
Darius is in that clip. >> Is Darius here or is he still
in Canada? >> Darius is back here. officer.
>> So, most of us have been here quite a bit. We know y'all
stream, right? We
>> Oh,
there it is. There it is. >> Read online. >> People
calling crawl is a bunch of [__] right? I don't see
anybody injured. There's no physical fights going on, right?
There's no issues going on. No problems. You guys are streaming,
right? Obviously, with the cameras in my >> Sorry, let
me turn the light off. >> I don't Hey, listen. I record.
You record. I don't care. Not a problem. I've never been a [__]
about that. Right. My issue is coming here and solving the problem.
We got told that there was a physical fight. >> This is
everybody in the house, right? >> They look injured.
>> They got told there was a >> whatever you have
going on will become a problem if we keep showing up, right?
Can't give you details about that. That's not how we operate,
right? But as far as like, you know, Darius, he's not here, right?
>> It's my understanding that Darius has some haters, right?
Am I clear in saying that? For sure. Yeah.
>> Darius isn't there right now. >> sorry. He's He's
in Austin. He apparently pulls up later. He's just not in the
house right now. >> This that >> Darius is at the
house. >> That My understanding is he has some >> He's
got some haters. >> My understanding >> Darius is
in his room. Oh, somebody told me Darius was out. >> No,
I saw him with his little bleach >> Oh, you know just now
when they were upstairs. Oh, I see. >> This might be a
part of that. This might be related to that. Okay. Mhm.
>> Locked himself in his room. Oh, true. He's dodging.
>> Now, here's the thing. Okay. For Darius, a situation.
He is here when they take the guy's GPU. Okay. >> Yeah,
you can say that. I >> Oh, that's where I felt like. >> Not
good. Not be good to be party to
>> He slipped out 100%. Yeah. Not good to be party to crimes
while they're happening and having them recorded when >> Of
course. >> So, there's a little bit of an issue. Not too
big. When you >> He's holding a a camera, right? That makes
you an accomplice to a crime. >> Good. I don't know what
the law is >> Um, one of these people has hidden my property
in this home and I've been trying to retrieve it for the past
couple hours and they've all been >> That's a civil issue,
dude. Like, we're not going to come in and toss it. >> Okay.
But you understand that I have it on video of somebody taking
it and I'm willing to leave. >> Wait, sorry. Do you have
video of somebody taking your Sorry, he
>> legacy, you took it out. He hasn't paid rent for a couple
months, but that's not like a US issue. That's a civil issue
you want. >> So, let me explain something. >> Listen,
officer, I just want my property back and I have someone on camera
taking >> So, you're willing to
you guys want to hear about the rules that we Okay, that is not
an offense cuz even though you say it's your property, you live
in the same house, right? Communal space, etc. >> No, I
don't I'm willing to >> listen to the officer first. >> What
would you >> Oh, what the [__] >> I don't
know who that was. That wasn't Nana, was it? That's not Nana.
That doesn't look like Nana at all to me. >> Listen to
the
>> Oh, maybe that's Nana. I I can't really see. Is it Nana?
I can't tell. So, there's a Kickst Nana that I thought lived
with them for a little bit. It must be, right? Cuz that's who
lives with them. >> That's the Asian woman who sometimes
mows the lawn and like >> Oh, this is girlfriend apparently.
Jesus.
I just randomly comes in. Can you please shut the can you please
shut up and let the officer talk? It's not my People are saying,
"What would you like >> I would like to, you know, maybe
present the video and have my property back because I just want
to leave and I don't want to leave without my property. It's
worth It's an expensive item worth around like $600. It's a graphics
card and I have somebody on video taking it." >> Okay.
Okay. So, >> somebody stole your graphics card. >> Okay.
On video, >> Okay. Which one of them is it? So, right now,
right, you're reporting at that. How much is the graphics card?
>> It's like $500. I mean, I took it out of my PC. Misdemeanor.
So, if you have it on video, you show me. You want to push >> I
just want to know where
>> it's the price of it. I I'm pretty sure that turns us
into like >> Oh, sure.
Yeah, you go from the to grand theft pretty quickly. >> I
have no idea. >> Yeah. Larars larseny grand lararseny.
Maybe you go from like something that is nothing to something
that is like oh they don't believe him. Well, I mean you could
say you don't believe him, but he says I have I have a video.
>> So I mean you just I think you just watch the video
that we have it. >> What was that? You can either give
up the graphics card or someone to go to >> Okay. So, please
give up the graphics >> If you have a video of it, you
show me who took it. I'll take that person and go right now.
Leave. We're not playing >> I'm willing to just take the
graphics card and I don't want anyone to go to jail unless they
refuse to give it back. >> Okay. Can we come to terms with
that and kind of sort this out the graphics card? >> Yeah,
we're trying to sort this out. He hasn't paid his rent for a
couple months. That's not nobody's problem. >> Hold on.
Time out. Time out. Time out. Both of you stop talking. As my
partner explained, you have two options right now. I've been
really nice and really chill. I promise you he's not that way.
He will take you to jail as quick >> I'm the nice guy.
You got the nice guy right now. You want to do this the easy
way or the hard way? This guy's watched some Brandon Carr videos.
>> Yeah. This is What is this guy's first day on the job?
Listen. Listen. I'm good cop. That that guy's going to be bad
cop. Okay. >> You ever heard of good cop bad cop? Tell
them about good cop bad cop. >> Oh [__] >> Oh,
as he can. I'm not calling him ask.
>> Listen to me. You keep interrupting me. Now I'm going
to be very stern. Your option is give the >> He doesn't
understand. You are >> This cop is awesome. No, this cop
is awesome. No, he is awesome because he's had to he talked to
an for like two minutes, he's done. >> You interrupt me
one more time. >> That's funny. These guys have been arguing
in Discords for way too long. Okay, they argue in Discords, they
just yell over people and now they're doing it with a cop in
real life and it's not going well. >> Please tell the cop
that he's doing some >> Listen, this is not a Discord debate
right now. >> Card back or he files a report and big dog
here hooks you up and takes you. We're not going back and forth
over he didn't pay his rent, so he took his property. That's
not how this works. Okay, you have an obligation to pay rent.
That means money. That does not mean you take things from people.
So again, with all that being said, big dog upstairs, big dog
right here. You have your two options. Which one will it be?
>> I Well, I don't have his card. >> Is big dog upstairs
god? >> I think big dog upstairs is god, which I don't
even know. >> You going to you're going to get locked up
by him or you going to die? What is >> I don't Yeah, I
don't know what he's saying there. I got no
>> but also
>> Legacy doesn't have the card, but Prawn has the card.
Why are they Why are they not just going like at this point it's
like, "Okay, jigs up. Let's go get the >> Um, appeal to
authority officer. >> Whoever he has on video taking that
card, they're going to go to jail. >> Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. If he has it on video, that's fine. I I did not take his
>> Do we put the banana in there? >> Oh, I think
we did put the banana in
>> That's nice. >> Yeah, you can sell that. I >> guess.
Hold on.
>> Legacy, are you out of your mind? >> That's nice.
Legacy, are you out of your
>> You literally went into his closed bag, grabbed his
graphics card, pulled it out, and said, "You can sell that
>> Hold on. That might be today. I don't know when this
clip is actually from. >> It says Oh. >> Oh, no.
It is. It is definitely from >> From today. >> Oh,
that is brutal. That is actually
Bro, what the are you How is he manning up? What happened? How
the is he manning up like this with the cops here? What
>> are so horny they want to just go to >> I need
I need Legacy. Can we get Legacy in the Discord at some point
once he's out of jail? Okay, we're going to have to get Legacy
on the stream cuz I don't know what in the world he was thinking
here after he pulls this out with not one camera pointed at him.
By the way, there's not one camera pointed at him. There's this
person streaming. There's Darius streaming. There might be Prawn
streaming. There's at least two people streaming. You take this
card. You open the the suitcase. You take the card out of the
suitcase.
>> Do we put the banana in there? >> Oh, I think
we did put the banana in
>> How do you forget this?
>> Watch the video. >> Listen, um, officer, so I
have a video of someone taking it, but over there show him what
you got. >> They claim that they don't have it. So, I believe
that someone else took it. There's multiple people in this house.
I don't know who took it. I just want it >> Do you have
it on video or not? >> Yes, I do. Let me show you in a
second. >> Was it one of these people? Yes, but I believe
he gave it to someone else or he >> Well, he did hand it
off, but I don't think that helps, right? If you if you break
into somebody's car and steal like their $800 sunglasses and
you hand them off to your buddy immediately, >> that's
just an accomplice. >> Yeah, you're you're like just handing
it off to somebody else. Like, you've already transferred the
property
property out of like a locked location. You got >> did
something with it.
>> And doing that is >> handed the baton and he's
like, I wasn't in the race. >> I don't know what y'all
do speeches. Y'all do the whole streaming thing. probably getting
a million likes right now. Of course, that's fine. >> It's
one of these videos right here. >> If he has evidence that
shows a crime as committed, we are obligated to pursue
>> I I >> Oh, if he if he has evidence of you doing
a crime, as he said, we're obligated to pursue that. Please go
get it. Please, just go get whatever the property is. He He seems
confident. Please just go get whatever the property is. I don't
even want to arrest you. Don't make me do the paperwork to arrest
you. Please save me the time.
>> They're not doing that. And that's going to make the
cops extra mad, >> bro. That's >> really The last
thing I want to do is pursue charges, man. >> I got you.
But if they're if they're being this way, like >> I've
been asking for it. I don't know where it is. If they can just
tell me where it is. Maybe they like they took it, but they might
have placed it back somewhere and I don't know where it is. Does
that make sense? >> Yeah. And all of them are saying they
don't know where it is. So that's that's a different thing. Like
I mean, somebody took it and they don't plan on getting back.
I mean, I I do this all the time, bro. They're going to They're
going to say they don't know where it is and then next thing
you know,
>> okay, I'm having some >> I This is why, dude.
They couldn't even say I don't know where it is. They couldn't
say I don't know where it is. That's not something you could
do after you are on tape stealing it. >> They said okay.
I mean, if he has it on video that I stole it. >> Yeah,
Legacy. Oh, yeah. Let him get the clip. Let him get the clip.
If he has it on video, I guess
>> I'm People are sending me clips.
can I get some information if you're one of them report? >> Uh,
sure. Not sure if you need it. >> I could just give you
my ID. >> ID works.
like definitely my
>> If you can not say the name out loud, that would be
great.
>> Dude, this is just open.
>> I think let What What's the name of the guy with the
long hair?
>> Legacy anti- autism pill. Let him be patient zero. >> Patient
zero.
>> Video for me, man.
>> So, this is just what you're saying. >> I'm just
trying to listen in the >> I am willing to leave tonight.
I don't have to be here. I just want my property then I can leave.
>> Wait. So, Prawn was live at this time. Can we line up
Prawn with the Prawn was live. Let me see if I can line up the
Prawnbot and get better audio on what like the cops telling them.
Hold on. Prawn's offline. Let's try to get on this Prawnbot.
>> This is once they're outside. This is not there. Dude,
the prawn bot is going to be disastrous. >> Okay, well
see if we get this must be when the cops get here. >> Is
prison working? >> Yo, IP you get from them. >> Can
you hold this for two? Can you I don't have a beer. >> Cops
are going to be here soon. >> Call the cops. >> Call
the cop.
Dude, what are you doing? >> No. I'm sorry. Legacy wants
this. >> It was a troll. >> He might.
This is 20 minutes ago with PR's camera and but I don't know
I I can't find where the cops are here.
>> Dude, this is uh whatever. I'm giving up. It might be
on Chicken Andy stream. We'll have to go back over to Chicken
Andy stream. >> I don't want to even
just get in contact with you for this for any reason.
>> What was that? >> He's got his camera shut off.
here. So you're on a flight here. >> Yeah, I left my car.
>> It's not He has to show a video to the officer. So that's
why it looks blurred out because it's um back to Florida. >> So
it was taken from here or somewhere else from here. One of them
was taken.
>> No, no, I was not in the plane. So how do you know?
>> I got some questions. Yeah. How do you know people live
streams? >> Okay. Who? >> Um it was
>> And where was the graphics card located? Was it in your
room? >> It was inside of my suitcase. >> Inside
of your suitcase. >> The green suitcase. >> Okay.
And somebody you have it on video of somebody opening up your
suitcase and taking it. >> What is their name? >> The
thing is I don't know if he still has it, but his name is >> Well,
if he took it, it doesn't matter if you still have steal stuff
and sell >> Okay, that's true. His name is His name is
Greg. >> Which one of them is it? >> It's the guy
on the Let me just show you the video here. So here here are
they going through my suitcase. This is my property right here.
>> Oh, it's >> the long hair. He takes it and then
that guy takes it and then he runs upstairs with it. >> So
he takes out and then he takes it. Yeah. So two different people
take it.
So, one of them was the reason he took it out and he >> legacy
is normally the reasonable person >> No, no, no. Legacy,
>> I swear to God, he usually is. >> That is not
true. What? How does he keep getting that reputation? I was told
Legacy was gay. He said he was gay and then he turns out being
all bunch of messy with like a woman >> and then he's like,
"Oh, well, when I get drunk, I get straight." Legacy never made
sense from day one. I won't be having this. Okay. Fair enough.
>> Can we look? Can we look in this? >> Watch it.
>> For the graphics.
>> So, this is this is where the cops are here, I believe.
>> The cops should be in here, right? >> Here's Adriana
Lee's angle talking.
>> No one called the cops. >> Oh, we got Adriana
Lee's angle talking to the cops. Let's go. Let's go. >> That
is not That's a crime. That means we have to act. Okay.
I do want to hear this from inside here.
>> That's irrelevant.
>> But my point is if he has evidence that shows a crime
has committed, we are obligated to pursue that if he chooses
to. Okay. The other option is we call it quits, get him what
he needs, and we bounce. Right.
>> Question. The evidence he's referring to is I touched
the microscope as last video. Then I put it down. I literally
know where it is. >> Okay. And that's fine. But if the
video doesn't show you taking and walking off, it's not there.
I'm not idiots. I look stupid. I get that. But I'm saying like
we look at it objectively.
>> It's a joke. This is so professionally >> I did
the same thing with them. You get what I'm saying?
>> I know. I know where it is.
>> No, you don't know where it's his thing. >> I
don't know where his thing is.
>> is chicken about to say chick there's no way that chicken
walks over with prawn right here and goes hey man I kind of recorded
you guys taking it there's no way right I'm just wondering if
that could possibly happen here cuz it seems like he's trying
to be like subtle >> it looks like it >> smart thing
to do would be to look for it right now and find it and not
>> if not we're going to investigate this and most likely
someone's going to
>> this is how I know
>> this is how I know legacy is the psycho He's the only
who actually walks around on the cold tile barefoot. All like
this will be >> sorry contain your autism for two >> Chicken
Andy is literally telling him about the crime he recorded on
stream in a place where only drama watch chicken Andy is going
hey there's literally like evidence of you committing this crime
on stream just so you know.
>> It seems like that's what's happening right now. Yeah,
but this guy but Legacy, his casual is to hang out in skinny
jeans and then to walk around barefoot on cold tile.
>> He's a psycho. >> That's crazy. >> He's
a psycho. He should be locked out. >> Thing is,
>> hold on. Hear me out for a second. Collectively, everybody
in this house, the smart thing to do would be to look for it
right now and find it and not go that route. If not, we're going
to investigate this and most likely someone's going to jail.
>> okay. You can't hear them quite, but it's like take
it. I think that's There's like video of you taking it.
>> There's a lot of people here. I don't know where. >> All right.
All right. Hey, why don't you help me try to look for your turn?
>> Your turn. Don't look out that you you
go here. >> I'm going to look for it cuz I'm going to get
some trouble.
can I have to laugh. They actually don't know it was recorded.
>> They actually don't know it's recorded. He's taking
them one by one.
>> What is his name? Sleas. Squeeze. >> I don't know.
Chicken Andy's the one who recorded them taking it. He absolutely
knows that it's recorded. He is like setting them up. >> Are
you sure he knows?
Because he's taking them one by one. S knows it's recorded. These
two are acting like Well, if if it's >> I sorry, I can
hear Chicken Andy. What >> do we put the banana in there?
>> Oh, I think we >> He's literally the person with
the camera. He is watching on his camera as >> Wait, isn't
Darius right next to him holding a camera? Darius has this has
this angle, too, right? >> People that look like they're
holding cameras looking at Legacy pull this graphics card out.
This is Chicken Andy's stream. I hear his voice saying like,
should we replace it with a banana? He knows he recorded them
doing this. He's holding the camera recording them doing this.
This is insane. >> Oh my god. Could you imagine if they
Wait, well, he didn't delete the VOD. The VOD is still up here.
What if he rushed to delete his VOD? >> I don't know. The
VOD's still there, but I This is some crazy [__]
right now. >> Someone did. Someone did. I agree. >> But
now the cops are here and and Squeeze wants to say, "Oh, I'm
not leaving until the graphics card. I have it in hand." Then
you have to give the graphics card. >> Oh, wait, wait,
wait. This is the wrong Sorry. Sorry. I went to that on Adriana.
Okay. I'm trying to listen. Oh, now Adriana mutes.
Now she has muted so that I think so chicken can explain. Hey,
I like recorded this. I think that's what it I think that's what
they're doing. I don't know why he just told Legacy to go say
you don't know where it is or sorry. I don't know where it is.
>> I don't know where this
No, Chicken is absolutely trying to warn them like, "Hey, just
so you know, just so you know, like you're going to be in trouble.
Gay Jesus takes GPU is the clip name. Gay Jesus takes GPU. Oh
boy.
He's absolutely trying to let him know and he's not being subtle
about it and they're about to be >> there officers. Let
me get over here. >> You can leave the door open. >> Uh
just for my safety. It's not an >> Leave for the graphics
card with no charges pressed. Give it to the guy. >> Isn't
that smart? >> I don't.
>> No one called the cops. No one called the cops, but
someone did. Someone did. I agree. But now the cops are here
and and Squeeze wants to say, "Oh, I'm not leaving till the graphics
card. I have it in hand." Then you have to give the >> Okay.
No, Chicken is absolutely trying to help them not get He is He's
absolutely saying he I think he just pulled both of them aside
and said, "Hey, just so you know, they also fought about it on
camera for an hour saying they weren't giving it back." Yeah,
I know they did that. I know, country captain. But I'm saying
that it's a little different to say, "Oh, well, we were just
bluffing. We didn't know where it was and you took it off camera,
but they took it on camera and were recorded and it was streamed.
>> The graphics card uh and not hold. >> Okay. Okay.
I'm
Please. >> Can we look? Can we look in this room? >> He's
been in a chicken suit the whole
>> House. My thing is safety. So, do not present any weapons.
Do not come out of course. No weapons in the house. Gucci. Cool.
Door stays open. Don't look for it. We can get out of here. Cool.
Remember I said I'm all cool respectful. I said y'all should
look for >> So who did they give the graphics card to that
they don't know where it is now? >> Happened here and y'all
decided you film and argue amongst yourselves.
>> Get the whole crew looking for it right now so that
way we can get out of here and you guys can go back to reading
it. That's what I would do. >> Let me look in his room.
Let me go pee real quick and then I'll look in his
>> I have to pee so bad. I'm sorry. But I'll look in his
room and then we'll
>> Okay. So, >> I looked it up.
>> This is theft. No matter what, it's under it's theft.
And the price range below 750 makes it a misdemeanor.
Uh I think it's a class B misdemeanor.
And you were right. It normally doesn't result in arrest. And
that's under the discretion of the police officers. One of the
reasons they can do it outside their discretion is impeding an
investigation. I'm sorry, but if if the cops talk to Legacy to
his face and say, "You're telling me you don't know where it
is. You're saying like if he's you're saying you didn't take
it. If he if he's got a video, it's going to be trouble. Like
it's going to be a problem." And then there's Legacy on video
taking the GPU.
Like it's of course they're going to arrest you. Of course they
are. Uh Squeeze said 600 bucks, guys. Squeeze >> He said
500 600 bucks. >> Yeah. So,
you know what I
But it's uh it's just crazy that it's crazy that he lied and
now I'm guessing that's why the cops are like, "Yeah, you >> Yeah,
cuz one of the things I I just said was impeding the investigation."
>> Yeah. Yeah, >> that would be this. >> Yeah,
for sure. >> Okay. Okay.
>> okay. It was in the closet in the
>> Wait, what? They give the GPU back. Wait, there's no
way that they don't give the GPU back. >> Stay upstairs.
>> Don't know. >> Don't know.
Well, fine. >> You don't know how to stop a dog? Maybe
this No, I'm just getting
>> one second. Let me see if
>> Oh, we got to flip back. Okay, >> it's a homeboy.
>> Okay. Does it Does it have to be those two people or
I mean >> it's So, I'm going to tell you how it works,
right? So, those two based off that video are >> both involved
in the theft of your >> So, they both >> are you
able to send that clips to me? >> Yes, I am. >> Okay.
Okay. This is like right where they're all looking for it. >> Just
give me my property back. But yeah, I have the thing to it. >> I'm
trying to get forward to where Legacy comes back down. >> Can
you go for the the theft, please? >> One second, guys.
One sec. >> Cuz they they technically bring the GPU back
out now. It's got to be around here, right?
>> We uh >> Okay, um >> send me a message.
>> Yeah, it takes time. >> Yes, correct.
>> Cuz like I'm just I'm trying to see
It was in your room. >> They go,
>> they take this back out.
>> They're worried about $500 brand squeeze now and avenue
to or civil charges of $1,500 each. Jesus. >> Is it worth
it? Is it worth it?
>> The content worth it? I don't know.
>> I mean, >> somebody needs to tell Pron to shut
the >> Is the content worth it? They literally said, "If
we find out that you're just doing this as a as content or a
joke, like you're we will we will [__] you >> That's
his exact quote right here. >> No, the cop said this when
he got there. >> No, but I mean protest. What did he just
>> Was the content worth it or something? And it's like,
dude, are you really going to You're like throwing these clips
up. You know, you have a bunch of audiences who are perfectly
happy to email the cops, send the clips to them. What the [__]
are you doing
>> here? Listen.
Wait. Wait. Did I go back too far? No. It's going to be fine.
>> We're never getting rent.
>> Is it worth it? Is it worth it?
>> The content worth it? I don't know.
>> Is it worth it? Is it worth it? Is the content worth
it? Amazing. >> I don't know. >> Incredible stuff.
Incredible stuff. >> And not all. >> Oh, whoops.
Not this one. We want to go back to Adriana or Squeeze
>> screaming at me. Just
>> man, it was not that hard. >> Just give me that
back. It was not that >> Okay, this is this is where they
found >> It's not that difficult. >> They're coming
to give it back. >> Let's see what happens now. Cuz I I
would have thought they'd let it go, but >> man. The way
the way Legacy and Prawn looked them in the eyes and said, "We
don't know where it is."
>> We don't have it. We didn't do this. >> Yeah,
he's got a clip, I guess. Is that >> Yes. Yes. >> Does
that resolve your issue? >> Um, may I know who had it?
>> I don't know. They they all went upstairs in your room.
We can investigate it more. You said this resolved your issue.
So, if this resolves your issue, we're happy to just let it be
that. >> So, do you want to put your chargers or not? We're
going to go that route. >> Okay. So, I could I could let
it go and >> let go. If you let it go, we're going to take
off and you guys do >> listen to this. So, they obviously
give it back, right? Yeah. >> But the theft still here
back. >> Thank you. Appreciate it. >> Theft still
occurred. >> Yes, sir. >> It's up to you. You can
still pursue charges or not.
>> Oh, does he actually say he's going to pursue charges?
Right. That's correct. So, they weren't holding a grudge or anything.
They're not annoyed that these took like a moment to have the
fear soaked in them to give it back. >> Yeah. It's not
the cops who are It's like It It sounds like they're like, "Yeah,
we can we can give this back to you." But now they're like, "Hey,
do you want to press charges, though? The theft technically did
occur."
>> This guy is bad cop, though. The the partner wasn't
lying. Okay. This guy is bad cop. The the partner was like, "Hey,
we if this resolves your issue, we'll go." He didn't say, "Yeah,
this is big dog." But the partner, the nice guy, was like, "We'll
just go if this resolves your issue." And he's like, "Yeah."
And then the partner is just like, "But you know, the theft did
still >> occur.
We're cutting a report >> I can get you a case somewhere.
And then >> the the actual content
to taking it. I can't influence you to press charges. That's
completely your own decision. I'm perfectly >> Oh, trust
me, Jacob. I'm totally fine with him pressing charges if that's
what he wants to do. I don't know if his community is generally
fine with you pressing charges when you have the option not to.
I think that's sort of an unspoken rule in the like IRL streaming
stuff that you don't get the cops involved unless you have to.
And like usually if things get like deescalated, you don't keep
the cops involved. The cops said me personally I wouldn't let
that slide. There's no [__] Wait, did I miss that?
>> Okay, we're cutting a report regardless. >> Okay,
I can get you a case and then >> before you didn't back
up to just let it be then. So, do you want to push your chargers
or not? We're going to go that >> Okay. So, I could I could
let it go and >> let it go and you let it go. We're going
to take off and you guys do what you >> So, here. Listen
to this. So, they obviously give it back, right? Yeah. >> But
the theft still here back theft still occurred. >> Yes,
sir. >> It's up to you. You can stop charges or >> Okay.
To me, we're cutting a report
>> I can get your case number. >> He said doesn't
matter to me. He said doesn't matter to me. Okay. Okay. Report
>> So, the report's going to stay. >> Report's going
to be generated regardless since you're reporting a >> Okay.
Got it. >> So, what it's going to say is the totality of
events that took place. And what I mean by that is exactly what
happened. We document. If you change your mind, >> they
have to write the statement for their visit. >> Yeah, sure.
>> Give us a call. Use that report number. If this satisfies
your concerns, and what I mean by that is there's no more beef
issues. Let it be what it is. Cool. But y'all are doing this
whole back and forth thing. >> They're not going to tell
you who took it. I'm just letting you know that. >> So
you guys can't like physically follow the guy, whoever went >> in
your house to to grab that, right? You can make the report. We
can investigate the report, but I'm not going to sit here everybody
down like a child and go through them if they're not going to
be willing to talk. They already are not willing to talk. They
were allowed the opportunity to go upstairs and find it. Magically,
it appeared, right? You know where I'm going with that? So, again,
for us to kind of sit here and go back and forth over something
like that, we're probably not going to get anywhere. >> Got
it. So, >> if you have any more information or evidence
that supports, you know, who actually took it? >> I mean,
I got a video.
>> So, I already know who took it. Two different people.
So,
>> Oh, he saw the video. I already know it was two different
people. >> This guy, the the other cop's trying to be nice.
This cop is not nice. I wonder if we could go back in any of
the VODs and find this cop specifically. I wonder if this isn't
his second or third trip to this house because he's like, you
know, I I got a video. We can go after these guys. Okay.
>> If not, we're gonna >> If I end up pursuing charges,
um who's going to be taken in if >> both of the people
in the video in the >> Okay, got it. Um >> you can't
just pursue against one. It's going to be >> Agreed. And
what would be the charge? >> Just theft. >> Theft.
Okay. Is that a misdemeanor? >> Okay. I would like to press
charges. >> Let me >> I think I think he's like,
"If it's a felony, I'll let it go. If it's a
[__] you." Like, oh,
>> Dude, that's [__] hilarious. Listen, I like
I like Prawn. I like uh Legacy.
I'm sorry. I feel no sympathy for them when they're on video
stealing the card from the guy. Okay, these morons decided to
lie to the cops about it. They're on video doing it and now he's
going to press charges. Like, I'm sorry. That's >> They
told him to call the cops. >> Legacy said call cops, bro.
Yes. Like, I
me, man. Make sure you understand this. It is not just a ticket
misdemeanor. This is a class B, which means they're going to
go in handcuffs and go to jail. >> Yes. Yes, sir. I understand.
>> Look at that video one more time.
>> Squeeze is like, I had to go to jail. They can go to
jail, too. >> Who it is?
>> That's actually even maybe a little more up knowing
that Squeeze had this exact thing happen to him, right? >> He
had to go to jail. >> Squeeze went to jail with Darius
that same night, right, for stealing Zeus's.
I don't remember if you watched that with me, but she went and
stole a bunch of waters from the back of Zeus's car. They took
something out of his car. >> Oh, after the merc stuff.
>> Yeah, after the merc stuff. They Zeus and they both
went to jail.
>> We're stealing bottles of water out of a >> There
was some other thing that went on there, but they were both Yeah,
there was they both went to jail.
They egged his car, too. They egged his car, so probably criminal
mischief or >> Oh my god. The Oh, yeah. >> But they
uh they both went to jail. I think Darius got some more serious
than Squeeze did. Squeeze didn't get anything that serious, but
he uh I I'm shocked that he'd get them thrown in jail for the
night. It's kind of [__] up. >> The thing I
remember about Zeus is he's the one who panced Darius in front
of like the people in the house or whatever while the cameras
were on. Yeah. >> Darius freaked the [__] out.
Rightfully >> Yeah, Zeus is a bit of a weirdo, but he was
also content. So, it is what it is.
>> Oh, boy.
All right. I can't believe that. Oh, also Merk got egged, but
Merk got egged by Darius entirely. That wasn't squeezed at all.
So, I'm just I'm not bringing that up, but uh anyway, >> keep
going. Keep going. >> Let's keep going. >> Actually
sent you on the link here.
>> Is this the video we were on? >> Yep. Yeah, he
he just went back to >> He just flipped his >> He
just flipped his thing back. >> Okay. Okay.
>> I kind of want to switch back to Adriana Le's view.
>> Where's my boyfriend? Well, I want to see when Big Dog
goes back inside to arrest them.
>> Oh, Sel, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. >> Let's
go, >> guys. We are
five subs away from another two hours on the stream. >> You
want to sub up now? We're going to cover this whole thing. We'll
cover any content associated. I'll see if I can get Legacy on
the phone in a couple
>> Usually, the two people I know in that house that I
can normally talk to are literally arrested. Okay, those are
the people I would go and like call them and say like, "Hey,
what's going on here?" >> They both got arrested. They're
supposed to be the nice guys. What the [__]
>> Wait, can you rewind? How did we get
>> I'm Oh, sure. >> Michael, you got to let me know.
>> How did I get around it? Yeah,
>> you have to press rewind.
>> So, that means that people have come to tell me what's
going on.
>> My screen
My chat was being like hella slow and now all of a sudden it's
really fast.
>> That means that always means someone's saying something
>> that I need to know about inside. >> Jesus and
Brun going to jail. Someone spamming in the chat. >> The
Asian girl is going to cry for her man. Which one of those two
got a >> Prawn. That's Prawn's girl apparently. That's
what people are saying. >> Prawn got money or something.
Where's David at?
>> He got blackmail over her. I don't know how wrong.
You got to let me know.
>> He is pressing charges. So, it sounds like the chat
is watching Squeeze stream. They just heard that he wants to
press charges.
>> Oh, soapbox is signing good gifted. Let's go. W Soapbox.
Thank you very
>> A friend. Can I get a lighter
>> A lighter.
Yo, this black man is so excited.
>> People getting arrested for theft and >> and it's
all the white dudes. >> All the white. He knew better.
He stood >> He just gets to observe.
>> Also, he's probably, you know, you you hear probably,
if this guy's not from Texas, you hear Texas, you know, southern
cops, they're all racist, right? He technically was in the room.
>> Maybe he was a little nervous, too. Okay. At first,
>> he was in the room when the theft occurred. Okay. Somehow
the two black men there when the theft occurred not getting pressed
at all by the cops. >> Very interesting. >> All of
the violence happening, all of the theft, all the crime, it is
white >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Uh send signal.
Thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
>> Tell Legacy to run. They're going to jail tonight. >> What's
going on? So
>> legacy is still inside.
>> Prawn. This is going to go outside and Prawn's going
to be getting arrested over the event. >> Learn how to
film.
>> She walked away. She walked away. >> Are they
not allowed to film an arrest? >> There's Prawn. Are they
not allowed? >> Are they not allowed to film an arrest?
Why did
What was she doing? >> I don't know. It might be a kick
thing. You're not allowed to film. You're not supposed to film
yourself breaking the law on kick is usually what it is. So it
might be >> Well, this isn't breaking the law. This is
someone getting arrested. >> But they might just be careful
there. Like people just get banned for no >> Okay. What
is happening?
>> So Ron walks out. He gets
>> Who's the black dude? Cuz he filmed
>> Uh I don't know who the black dude is.
>> Is this real?
>> I'll walk you over there.
>> Not out there yet.
I'm getting walked away. Oh, Legacy is out there. Oh, she just
didn't film any of it. Oh, >> yeah. That's why I said,
"What the [__] she doing?" >> I don't know.
We We still have the squeeze view anyway. >> I'm not sure.
>> Can I talk to you?
>> It shows that
kind of scary. I'm letting you know though, with the digital
age, you guys doing all your streams and Twitches and things
like that. If it comes, >> there's no way I went all the
way back. something important that they were have where I started.
>> They're about to get walked out at 253 or something.
251. There we go. >> Okay, so they get walked out
time, but it was in the afternoon. >> Let's Now we got
the context. Okay, this is where we stopped. We did a little
back and forth here. Now we got the context. We can actually
see what's going to go what is going to happen when the cop runs
over or walks over rather right after
right after um they've arrested everybody. We actually know what
happened. I've got the cont. What time did this happen at? >> Um,
well, this was while I was on a plane. Okay. So, it was around
like
>> I can't tell you the exact time, but it was in the afternoon
for sure. >> Um, but I can go back in the clips and investigate
a little bit more, but I don't know if that's y'all's job, but
>> No, I mean, I could probably just pull up the clip and
see. >> Okay. It's all on kick.com. That's where we uh
Sure. >> Sure. But what was your uh name, >> Uh,
the Masters badge number 487. >> Let me check if >> So,
was this all a prank? Is Squeeze a
>> No, this is I mean, it's not a prank. They are Prawn
and Legacy are >> Yeah, they're morons. >> They took
this man's property. They thought that you could tip for tat
when someone owes money for rent. No, the [__] you
can't with their property. And then they
told him, "Go ahead, call the cops on us." Yeah, call the cops.
>> I will say that it appears Squeeze did not call the
cops in the first place.
>> Squeeze didn't even call the cops. It's just like the
chat called the cops and said there was going to be a fight or
something. So, it wasn't even squeezed to call the cops, but
So, that gets him out of this a little bit. He did have the option
not to press charges. I >> What I don't know when he was
given the opportunity to press charges, I don't know if he knew
that meant that they were going to arrest them. That was >> No,
he knew it. The cops said explicitly, "If we arrest them, it's
a class B felony. They will go to jail >> Oh, he did say
that. >> Yeah. Cool.
>> Yeah. The cops literally said precisely. This is a class
B felony.
They will both go to jail. And they also said, "You can't just
press charges against one of them. It's both of the people in
the clip. We will have to arrest both both of them and take them
both to jail for the night."
>> He said, "Yeah, cool." >> I Well, I can't remember
if he said, "Yeah, cool." But he didn't stop them. >> I
would like to know how I could like communicate about the case
and >> talk about it and get more information on it.
>> Me and Dar
um do I need any of that? Uh, get ready. >> 47. Can I get
the case number for the >> Uh, class B misdemeanor. If
I said felony, whoops. Class B misdemeanor. So, a class B. It
was like higher than the lowest one.
>> Yeah. Cop said handcuffs, jail.
>> Here's my business card. Has my name, badge number,
has >> Yeah. I Riy was telling me about this earlier. He's
like, I'll keep an eye on it, but I think it's like fake. Like
I think it's kayfabe. And I was like, okay, well, let me know
what happens. And he's like, oh, the cops just got here. Uh,
it's definitely not. Oh,
>> email I think. >> Uh, you guys are way behind.
I don't know if you guys need to refresh the um I don't know
if you guys need to refresh the stream. Yeah, you're way behind
right now. >> Got it. >> Yeah, email's on the back.
>> Chat's cool. I appreciate it. >> The screenshot
I linked in Discord. Relevant to the drama.
>> Relevant to the drama. Relevant. >> Is the new
IRL streamer meta just getting arrested?
>> Appears to be. Well, that's what happens when people
feel like they have to continuously push the envelope. >> Oh,
yeah. M was apparently in the chat. The police will help you.
They will help you, bro. Squeeze your The cops will help you.
Vandalism. Do not fold. Call the cops. You I'm calling the police.
Squeeze. You are an idiot. Oh,
Mark called the cops.
Oh, Mark called the cops. >> She said, "Let them know it
was me."
>> Squeeze. You are an idiot. Ask him about pron. I called
the police. Darius at Darius IRL mold harder. Adriiana takes
her brother's aderall. She has no room to talk. Adriana takes
her brother's aderall. She has no room to talk. >> Does
her brother not need that Adderall? >> I I don't know.
Sorry. I have to >> um Pretty much any officer should be
able to answer your questions. Um >> so I don't have to
directly contact you. I can contact anyone else. >> Yeah,
they should be able to pull up the report. Um this is my Friday,
so don't call me tomorrow. I'm not going to >> Got it.
Um, >> what else? I mean, basically after this, right,
I mean, you're most likely not even have to show up in court
or anything. Most of it's most stuff's
>> So, you I mean, you might not even hear back from us.
Most likely not going to. Got it. >> Uh, cuz it's all handled
courtside. I don't even know if maybe an attorney will contact.
I don't know. >> So, it's all stuff that we don't deal
with. Um, >> what else? >> I just appreciate your
help and you know, I >> I know that this happened while
I was away. I mean, I could show you the itineraries of the flights
and everything. You know, my goal coming >> Yeah, I don't
need the itinerary. I mean, you could have gone to Walmart, bro,
and come back and your taken, >> right? Um, like I said,
my goal coming here was to just grab my stuff and leave. I don't
want to live here anymore. I'm moving out of this house. I lived
here for a couple months and now I don't want to live here. >> Okay.
Um, >> he's not my friend. I don't >> I got you.
>> If you if you do decide to change your mind on pursuing
charters, you don't contact us. You contact the district attorney's
office. >> We don't we don't do the whole >> Can
you repeat that one more time? If >> so, if you do decide
like let's say tomorrow, okay, >> you're like, I actually
don't want to pursue charges anymore. >> Um, contact the
Travis County District Attorney's Office. Okay. >> They're
going to want to know the case number, whatever. Like, I don't
want to pursue charges on these guys anymore. Okay. Yeah. Um,
we we don't go into attorney's office to be like, "Ah, they're
dropping charges. That's not our >> Okay. So, it's it's
me. It's on me now. It's not on the state. The state is not pressing
charges, are they? >> You're the one pursuing charges.
If you want to stop pursuing charges, you have to contact the
district attorney's office cuz once we >> Can we stop pursuing
charges right now? >> He can. >> I think you should.
>> It's not going to happen.
>> Shut the [__] up, Chicken Andy. Go somewhere
else. Dude, what the
uh I will say I think that is for the CX people, which chicken
Andy is a part of that crew, right? I think this is generally
what's expected. You don't press charges. If you can get out
of it without the cops, you know, hurting people, you you pull
back. >> This is normally why cops won't let you come over
while they're talking to somebody. This is coming over and trying
to influence and pressure him to drop charges in front of your
face. >> Yeah, but what is the cop? >> Roast this
chicken. >> Is the cop going to take chicken Andy seriously?
Guy in a chicken costume being like, I think you should drop
the charges, Ashley. >> Arrest this one, too. He's obstructing
justice. He's doing something. Witness
>> Yeah. I have no idea why. I don't think they can get
him on witness intimidation in that suit. Okay. I just don't
think it's possible. >> Any questions? >> Uh, no
questions. I have your business card and I thank you for helping.
>> Cool. For sure. You need to grab me anything from the
house? >> Uh, I have some stuff in the house. Yeah. Um,
am I I want to know if I'm like obligated to leave or >> I'm
watching. He's there. >> You live here? So, you tell him
it's one of those furry that the administration is working. If
they're saying you haven't paid rent in a few months, that's
why they took your grace card. Whatever, right? Um they're legally
required to file for eviction. >> So, they can't just like,
hey, you got to leave. They can say that, but you're not required
to once whoever the owner or the main lease. >> Justice
that leech loser squeeze owes them over $1,000 in unpaid rent
and utilities, etc., and leeched the whole time he was there.
That's probably true. That's got I got to That's probably true.
Unfortunately, you cannot steal from people. And if you're going
to do crimes, you should be better at doing crimes. If you're
going to do crimes like a on camera and then tell the cops, I
didn't do that crime that they got me on camera doing, then you
probably deserve to spend the night in jail to slap some sense
into you. Okay. And I like Prawn and Legacy. I like both of them.
But this was maybe the least required trip to jail I've ever
seen in my entire life.
>> In terms of like it didn't have to happen. It should
happen now. Like maybe it could teach them something, but yeah,
it didn't have to happen. >> And the real Dr. Cube, I am
half white. Half of me really [__] with uh calling
the cops and sending someone to jail.
>> Yeah, sure. Um it doesn't Oh, thank you for the technical
actually doesn't matter that they lied to the cops at first.
Yeah, I know. It probably doesn't matter, but it depends. Or
sorry, it changes how the cops handle the situation cuz guess
what the cop said? Okay. The cop was like, "Oh, if you're done,
we'll just go." And then the other cop was like, "Oh, you know
what? With these guys, you know what? You can always press charges.
The theft still happened." Right. The cop doesn't act that way
when you don't lie to them. When you don't waste their time,
when you don't them, right? Cops don't act that way.
>> They'll they'll like totally They'll totally change
how they act with you. You just act like a real person, real
dude with cops. They'll be kind. Okay. I I know this. I have
a history of having incredibly like positive interactions with
cops, okay? I'm the whitest person. They love me. All right,
just be good. You'll be fine. >> He is on the house. They
have to file for an eviction through a justice of the peace court,
right? >> And then you have to be court ordered to >> Okay,
got it. >> I am white. I I know how to deal with the cops.
Okay.
>> trying to cause problems. I'm just breaking it down
so you don't try any more stunts or anything like that. These
legally required are allowed to be here until you get formally
evicted by a second. Cool. >> Yeah, cool. I'll just go
ahead and grab some more stuff. >> We're being sent these
clips right here. >> Going to reveal that. Um,
>> so yes, dude. Dude, I've been in your situation. I've
been a gambling addict for years. Okay, I understand why you
don't have the money right now. >> Oh, Gunnar Gunnar called
Squeeze earlier here and he's going to explain that. Hey, even
if you're gambling, even if you can't pay rent, okay, what you
can do is you can get your your property. I know exactly. I've
been in your exact situation before, guys. >> You are making
75 an hour on KP right now with 750 viewers. You get that, >> Uh
no, I don't get that. Is that true? How do you know? >> Are
you Stop Stop playing dumb. I am I'm in the same program. Okay,
here's what you're going to do. You're going to beg for subs
for the next 10 hours straight. You're not going to end your
stream, but you're going to argue with them. I want you to get
back in there and force them to be exhausted by your presence.
They can't kick you out. They have no verbal agreement whether
or not like they can't steal your property either. >> They
did. They already did. >> No, don't. Wait, this is before
the cops get there, right? >> Before the cops get there.
Yeah, >> cuz he told the cops, "I'm leaving. I don't want
to be here anymore." Yep.
Yeah, I know. So, your retaliation is to not let them sleep tonight.
>> I'm sure one of those losers has work in the morning
at their gay little real life job. So, what you're going to do
is just torment them and be annoying as for the next 10 hours
straight and then I'm going to watch it. Okay. >> All right.
You know what? Fair. Fair.
>> I would not, by the way, I would not trust Goon on what's
legal and illegal with regards to evicting roommates and after
we watch what he did to Murk. Okay. That was 100% illegal what
he did to Mark.
>> That ending where he's like, "Do this thing that's going
to be really annoying. It's going to trigger the out of them.
I I'm going to watch it. It's going to be content for me. Go
ahead. Do it. Do it." Okay, buddy. >> All right. This is
it.
>> Maybe don't steal and you won't get >> arrested.
Is that [__] up?
>> You're like the whitest [__]
>> You're white, too, aren't you? >> Not that white,
>> man. Milk them. I don't think I think this fixed it,
right? >> I don't think in my 12 years of streaming I've
ever gotten anyone >> Shout out. >> So, I saw OBS
was like lagging. It was It was my OBS. I don't know what's going
on with my OBS, but it seems to be fine
>> See, this is this is a bit who hated
>> Zeus. He's a different guy that lives in South Carolina
now on a boat. >> Yeah. All right. >> He doesn't
live out here no more. I don't think I've ever heard this to
someone to be honest. >> I like Zeus. I forgive him. He
He's content king and uh >> he really knows how to create
content. >> Squeeze. What are you going to do when you
have no friends >> and you're gambling? I >> I wonder
I wonder what I'm going to do, chicken. I wonder why you care
so much what I'm going to do. Huh? >> Bro, you're young,
bro. >> I am young. Yeah. And I look up to people like
Zeus IRL. Brian Parnell, the dude's a G. He was a vet in the
military. You went to Iraq at 18. Did any of you >> Squeeze
doesn't believe this. Squeeze doesn't care about him. >> You
go to Iraq at 18. >> Aren't you in Iraq?
>> Maybe I will go. >> This is a David song. It >> Maybe
I will be a part of the military after this. Maybe I will. You
>> [__] [__] You look up to him.
>> Thank you for calling me. I appreciate >> Cuz
you look up to someone that you can't [__] do. >> That
you told the cops that you would leave, so you have to leave.
>> The cops say >> anonymous just $2. You have >> Why
is he playing David? That guy killed the girl. >> Did you
not Did you or did you not tell the cops you were leaving? >> The
cops said that I have legal rights >> I'm asking a question.
>> Yeah, we see the David song. We're here. >> Did
you not tell the cops you were >> And I'm not answering
your question,
but I might leave. Who knows? >> I think we would all appreciate
it if you left. >> I'm just having a little conversation
here, you know. >> Yeah, with three. >> We sentent
$3. Please being petty going to get him sent to small claims.
And now he has a police report explaining he lived here. So all
that for a bill. Smart boy. Lol. >> Uh thank you. I'm really
smart. You know I have >> I have a lot of intelligence.
So
>> all of these guys, dude, it takes a certain kind of
person and probably just an IRL. Yeah, probably just an IRL streamer
to be like the guy who everybody else wants gone. Everyone wants
you to leave, right?
And you just want to hang out. I feel like that takes a certain
kind of guy and it's every IRL streamer is just that guy. >> You
have to leave is what I'm being.
>> Oh yeah. Did the officer say that? >> Not that
I hate it. By the way, >> invited him to sit down. >> Did
he say it to you? >> Obviously, we love these guys making
content for us to review. Okay. >> Did you invite him to
sit down and talk >> back there? Yes, I did. >> Yes,
he did. >> Did you?
>> All right. Yeah. Yeah. I just looked at
Oh, we got Darius pulling up. >> 3 hours 10 minutes. Hold
on. I'm going to refresh this really quickly. We're going to
go back to 3 hours 10 minutes.
And I love
>> just hit $1 here. >> Here. We'll make sure you
find >> rights here, guys. I'm not sure what you
>> Oh, there's my uh >> This is what Zeus did. He
had to complete it. Well, I think Zeus also said he was going
to leave. He told the cops he was going to leave. And they're
hoping that if they say that to Squeeze that he'll leave, right?
he'll realize Zeus got was forced to leave that same way. So,
they're trying to recreate that to get him to go. >> Oh,
my my lamp actually. You know what? I'll leave it here just as
a a nice
>> Is that your lamp? >> This is my lamp. I bought
this lamp with my own money. >> Take the lamp, dude. >> We
don't want the lamp, dude. Or you can leave it and we'll remember.
Squeeze.
>> just a squeeze. >> Why would he leave if he lives
there? Um, I don't think he has to leave. Yeah, definitely remember
me. >> But just take it. [__] it. >> Uh,
no. I'll actually give it to you so you can sell it. >> No,
I'll admire. We'll remember this day >> We will remember
this day. >> There's an honor. >> I actually have
to use the restroom. Um,
>> So, if you guys can give me a moment.
>> Squeeze. Get the [__] out of the house right
now. I'm not [__]
Get the out of the >> Why would Darius Why is Okay. One,
why is Darius doing this with his glasses on? Okay.
Bro, with all the tattoos and the bleached hair and the shaved
head, you still you still look like a total nerd with the glasses
on. But two, why is he trying to pretend that he can press this
guy, Darius? You can't press this guy even a little bit. You're
you're like one cop call away from going to jail. Why are you
acting like you can press him? He knows you can't press him.
He knows you can't [__] with him.
Thank you. Let's
try this way over there. Sire. >> Okay. I'm guessing >> I
don't want Darius to crash up. >> I'm guessing this is
around where he gets another call from Gunnar and Gunnar is going
to tell him, "Get the get the back in that house." Okay. Get
back in that house right now. >> Oh [__]
>> Walks over to his car.
>> Oh god.
stealing my property doesn't rent though. I was just a piece
of >> his chicken.
>> Stealing my property, man. >> Pay the rent, though.
You're saying that they treated you like dogs. You didn't pay
the rent. >> Stealing my property doesn't make up for >> I
mean, it was a troll. >> It's not a troll to to steal people's
items, man. >> I mean, it's not how life works. >> It
was a troll. >> It definitely wasn't because I've I've
asked for it multiple times. It was not a troll. I have I've
asked for it multiple times on camera. Nobody gave it to me and
I wanted to leave with my property and nobody has it >> and
nobody gave it to me. trolled. You're trolling.
>> Stop trolling, dude. >> I just want the rest of
my property. I don't know >> what else >> if I left
something.
>> Okay,
last look. I believe >> just want my uh stuff back and
>> you donated the lamp. >> I will uh >> we'll
use the lamp as a >> donate the lamp
>> to uh you. >> Thank you. >> I'll make sure
it's put in a good spot. I'll put a sign over saying squeeze
was >> It's not funny. This is not This is not um a joke.
This was >> This is harsh. >> Wrong. Because I was
flying. >> Wait, don't forget your [__] >> Squeeze.
You have legal rights here and they have to give, >> right?
That's true. They do have to >> So, what what's
>> um Well, I have to uh utilize the
>> Yeah, I have to utilize it. >> You want me to
wash? >> No, absolutely not.
>> Are you kidding me? You think I You think you guys are
cool with me? Like you don't trust me. >> Are you guys
like >> What are you looking at? What are you on? Drugs.
>> He's actually >> See you in a second.
>> Okay, we're looking through for the next
>> How was Explain. Why do you feel the way you feel? >> Cuz
I have a small. >> Is the stream stuttering again? It shouldn't
be. >> I'm sorry. I'm skipping through things. >> It
could be their quality, right? >> Okay. Why is everybody
so uh mad and >> Oh, no. Something's going on with my >> Are
you guys defending thieves? People that take people's property.
>> Yeah, something is going on weird. Hold >> Content.
So, we've all been here on empty content. >> You guys are
uh
should not defend thieves, guys. Seriously. >> That's what
you think. You think everyone's thieves, bro. No one. >> Okay.
So, you guys are not on on their their side, right? >> No.
Okay. Got it. >> Got it. >> Got your What's your
uptime? Good job. You got a good stream in. Hopefully, you find
someone else to leech.
Just need a you know a couple of >> see if this >> maybe
you know things to >> a little I fix some stuff with Discord.
>> I don't give a [__] I'll send you >> Do
you really you have patience? I have lots of patience.
>> What makes you have such patience?
>> Yeah, you don't bother me. >> No, I don't. Why
would I? I don't bother >> Uh you bother a lot of people.
Who do I >> Darius. The chat is saying it lagged a lot
here and they might have bother him because I don't want to.
>> Did you bother? >> Oh, I'm seeing I'm seeing that.
>> Was that I'm sorry for the scam donations, guys. People
>> although I don't know >> keep sending you know
Russian racism. So I keep >> his phone would default to
his signal
Please stay until charges on.
>> Why are you following me, man?
>> Quit following me, man.
>> Oh, okay.
Do you think this is Chicken Andy like trying to make up for
the fact that you're the reason why your boys are in jail? You
recorded it. How do you have any energy for this dude? You're
the one who recorded it. >> I don't know. Uh, can you read
this out loud when you see it?
>> You guys are all going to have to
follow me in here.
>> Stream would have lagged for you guys. You're all going
to have to refresh.
>> up. A man today. >> What was that?
>> You were a boy when this stream started. You were a
man now. >> You think so? >> Oh, Squeeze has got
to know that Goon's just farming him, right? You think When do
you think Squeeze figures it out that Goon is just going to give
him the advice that lets him farm content? Do we When are we
going to see it? I don't know, man. What makes you What makes
you say that? >> You were one of one of these things. You
had the comeback of the century and you >> I did and and
I knew I was. But I mean, it's ridiculous. They still stole my
stuff. And it's not right. So,
>> I think in your position in your position being an 18-year-old
getting pressed 1v6, I think you did the right thing to defend
yourself and protect
>> You didn't even call the cops, but the cops got called
anyways and you just handle it. Okay. >> Correct. I handle
feel bad about that.
>> You you were the underdog and you came out 1v6 and you
won. Now, technically, I sent you the tax. >> Technically,
a 35second delay. I counted. How long is this? >> Notice
they need a written document and you must provide the landlord
must provide that before you're technically evicted. Well, you
already got the W. The only thing that you can [__]
up now is said you're welcome to come to the boat. He's going
to try to get Zeus to drop the uh charge cuz I think you and
Zeus are cool, right? >> Uh I mean I find him cool. I just
have some legal issues against him that I want to get rid of,
man. So
>> what you want to do your next step is get rid of those
and then you're going
>> He's already he's already said that he wants you there.
>> Okay, perfect. All right. Uh I might go
um but you know at the same time I don't want to be Shuby's slave
again. So I we'll try to find some sort of middle ground within
that boat. I was a slave to a Filipino 5 foot tall egirl for
4 years of live streaming. Okay, tough in >> 3 seconds
for my test to show up on stream. Then how the is my voice delayed
by that much? There's no way. >> What do you mean? Five.
If you guys are that far behind, it's got to be fine. >> All right.
You know what? You're not
>> God tent and be a man.
Enjoy it. They can't technically evict you, but you don't have
to overstay.
Just ask them. Ask them if you can sleep for the night and then
you can leave in the morning. Pack your And then
>> You're making You're making 120 an hour right now. You're,200
viewers. Get the >> Holy. You're not wrong. What the [__]
>> You're the king of kick tonight and we're all proud
of you.
>> No, you're you're a great deal. Appreciate you for sticking
around.
>> Is Goon his manager? A Goonar is just trying to farm
him for content. It's good content.
>> Y'all, thank you. It's amazing. Congratulations on your
man now. All right. Talk to you later. See you, man. Oh my god.
You know, that'll be a good shout out to Good. I'll do I'll do
exactly what he told me. I mean, he he he has good advice and
I'm going to ask stay the night and I stay the night and I'll
leave in the morning and then I'll move on to other things and,
you know, I won't hang around thieves anymore because theft is
bad and shouldn't steal other people's people. You shouldn't
steal other people's property and stuff. And yeah, hope everyone's
having a good night, man. Just keep the positive energy in here.
My name is Squeeze. >> This guy's going to have some troubles.
>> You don't know me. Uh I always have people harass me.
Um and you know, they take my stuff and they took my stuff. Um
and they are in trouble now. So just don't don't be much harassing
me and don't be taking my stuff.
>> I think this is shooting.
Don't squeeze. >> Yeah. Why you spamming me, man? It's
>> I'm on the phone.
Leave on him and it will be all cool. >> Wait. Wait. You
said what? Can you speak up? This guy's blaring music in the
>> If you come on the boat, Z will wave and everything
will be all Gucci. >> Okay. See, will remove the the charges
when I go on the boat, right?
>> Yeah. And then you'll be all right. >> All right.
And then
it's a W. You just won.
>> I don't even know who the this is. >> Would you
come on the boat and die with
>> I've never seen >> I mean I'm not trying to die.
>> Oh. Oh. Okay. >> But I mean she maybe I will.
>> Yeah. I don't know if you've been watching but >> yeah
cowboy. I remember cowboy from uh constant fear for our life.
They trying to blare music to get him out. Almost certainly.
Yes.
>> There's no way.
>> I would have been out the house if it was Adriana playing.
>> Well, I mean,
>> I'd be gone. >> I'm just Darius came in and kind
of pressed him and then I don't know. I feel like I feel like
they got to be careful if Darius presses this guy like hard.
Darius liked him and was like, "You get the out of here now.
I don't >> Yeah, he backed off. He's like, I don't want
Darius to crash out." >> Yeah. I Because I think Darius
is He's on parole, right? Like he's technically He's like on
B. He's out on bond right >> Not parole. Sorry. He's out
on bond. I don't know why I said parole. He's out on bond. >> Not
whenever I get back to Florida and whenever I, you know, get
involved. >> He's going to be pretty good cuz he also I
think they didn't put him back in jail when he violated part
of his protective order. Right. So, but I mean me and him, we
talked on the phone. Um, and uh, you know, we were going to,
you know, plan something out. Um, and I know a lot of people
are, you know, negative on my dedicated IP on my VPN. So,
it's going to drop so many people stream, but whatever.
Um, how do I It should be back. Is it back, guys? Are we back?
>> Someone said refresh. We are back.
>> But you have the You have like this spiraling thing.
>> Yeah. Well, I've um >> I have a setting here that
I need to >> Yeah, Mount Fuji Cog. >> Sorry, I need
to restart Discord now.
Uh it's something to do with my VPN with kick just wouldn't let
me connect. So, the whole internet breaks for like regular VPNs
now. I don't know. I'm going to I'm just going to switch. I'll
go cancel whatever I'm paying for and switch over to something
else cuz this is not working. All right, we should be back. We
should be good.
You don't know what I'm
going again and you can hop in the
>> I have not gotten that out of my head. I'm in the presentation.
>> Amusement park. You're going to race a car. You're going
to go out into the wilderness or you're going to >> No,
no, no. Wrong. Wrong. Wrong. I will do something special. And
it it involves you. Maybe I shouldn't have said that, but it
involves you, cowboy. You will be involved. doing
homes with Tommy and me. >> What? No, no, no, no. Listen,
I'm going to hang up this call if you mention that once again.
All right, I'm going to hang it up.
>> Boy, has the boat so messed up. And they're still in
SC after days. It's not
>> It's a possibility.
>> All right, see you later, man. Holy
>> I need you guys to flag up if you're in the chat now.
>> Jesus, man. Fen, I appreciate the uh the donation, dude.
>> Guys, what what do we do? I mean, we're we're going
to kick him out at any time.
>> Excuse me. >> He's considered a squatter. You
can kick him out at any time.
>> Why are you considered a squatter? You can kick him
out at any time. >> Why are you blaring? He's considered
a squad. You can kick him out at any time. >> Anonymous
just tipped $1. We all know you were crying. Just hurry up and
cry like the little [__] you are. Trying to act so
proud after snitching to the police. Haha.
>> You can kick him out at any time. >> Holy [__]
Hold up. I think he just did
>> If it's not any >> Yo, thank you for the five
gifted, man.
>> Appreciate that. Five gifted, dude.
>> What are you doing, man? Seriously, >> I was just
streaming, bro. >> He's considered a squatter. You can
kick him out at any time. >> No, you're you're you're messing
with some with some stuff here. Yeah, I'm just saying hang out
with all of your friends with me. >> You're doing some
some weird [__] You're blaring your speaker with
every >> I can't hear you.
>> What are you saying,
>> I'm having enough of that speaker of yours, man. >> It's
my speaker. It's my >> Please do not speaker. My burn.
>> That's true. My speaker, my >> Okay, dude. Please.
>> This is uh Listen, you're never going to beat Chicken
Andy in this, okay? It's just about being annoying. You're going
to lose. Even if this guy's 18 and chicken and he's 30, whatever,
you're not going to beat him.
>> I He's going to win every time.
>> He should not be happy to win. >> Well, I don't
know if he's happy to win, but he's going to win. >> He's
considered a squatter. You can kick him out at any time. >> My
speaker my brother. >> Yes, that's true. >> That
must be a hell of a [__] he's
>> Wait, how fat was that? >> He's considered a squatter.
>> Someone's face is considered,
>> guys. So, we're
>> It's just the same facial
>> He's considered a squatter. You can
see he's considered a squatter. You can at any time.
>> He's trying so hard. He got the
Look how hard he's trying. Throwing smoke in someone's face is
considered a soft, man. >> That's what he should be doing.
>> Thanks so much, babe.
>> Just chill.
>> Is he finally leaving? Hello.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Weirdo, dude. Oh, he's taking the chair.
what the hell is wrong with this? What the hell is wrong with
everyone in this crib, man? Guys, let's just regroup here and
and think about what happened. I I know you guys had to endure
that volume.
Um, well, let's try to start the car, make sure that we're going
really dealing with a lot and I I've gotten texts that, you know,
I should leave. So, what do you guys think, chat? I mean, I I
Me to be here. So, I mean, uh, holy,
>> here's the unfortunate thing. Okay, the unfortunate
reality. I don't think Squeeze is going to be good content on
his own. I need somebody else to interact here. >> Mute
it. All right. >> Somebody came to talk to him.
>> To uh someone who is in Austin, Texas that can uh invite
me. I'm sorry. I had to mute because I had to talk to someone
and it's not looking good. So, um, and I legally can't say this
certain stuff because, um, because there's problems going on,
guys, and it's not because it's not with me. It's not with anyone
else. It's with someone else. Okay? I said, "Come on." No, he
did not, bro. No, he did not. Guys, who do I like stay over for
the night, man? Like, what do I do, guys? Who's in Austin, man?
I I'm getting DMs saying that.
Who Who is this? Jamie sneak into Jaime's house. What?
Why would I do that? I'm not going to sneak into someone's house.
Hold up. We're seeing uh Goh loves gas station. Oh, the OG spot.
The OG spot. Yeah. No, I could go to the >> Just tip $1.
I am sorry, bro, that you had to deal with them stealing.
They have problems in ET Hotel, bro. Let's go. >> Yo, Slim,
thank you for the dollar, man. Yeah. Uh, you're good, man. Um,
it's not even here, first of all. She's with >> Go to a
hotel. >> Go to a hotel. >> Girl, I'm kidding. I
would never want to. Um, what the [__] >> guys?
I might have to just leave this, you know, place. I'm not going
to lie. >> He's no one to go to and still felt comfortable
burning the last bridge he had by pressing charges. Very smart
guy. No, he technically Okay, he definitely
>> go to college.
>> He also technically has a bridge with Shuy. It's just
he doesn't like Shuy treats him like a [__] so he
doesn't like being Shuy's. >> That's what Goon was talking
about. He was like, I had to be a to a five five foot Filipino
girl for years. deal with >> Yo, Sim signal. Thank you.
>> Good sub, man. Appreciate that, man.
>> Um, exposed. Yeah, man. I exposed. There we go. What
do you guys think? Everybody go uh say that. Everybody knows
that about him, though.
>> Call Ice. Wait, hold up. M is saying I'm not back from
Japan yet. Oh,
you're good, M. You're good. You're good. You're good. Don't
even trip. Don't even trip. Don't even trip. Uh, Difo, what's
up, man? Um, Goon, uh, let me text you, actually. I don't know
what he's doing right now. >> Oh, Goon is watching. >> Goon
was trying to get him to be able to go to Shubies, but he Yeah,
>> they're trying to get him to go to
>> my headphones. Signal, thank you for the gift that's
sub to fell pow. Thank you. Thank you. Why are IRL streamers
like this? Difficult to say
relic. Very say
>> the Tylenol. Could be Tylenol. Could be the Tylenol
early on. >> All right. I'm sorry guys. So, um, let's see
here. Um, oh my god, viewership surprising. I feel like I have
to just [__] do something here. Take calls.
>> Yeah. Yes. Do something.
Dance. >> Yo, send signal. Thank you for the five gifted.
I appreciate you. >> Oh, send signal with the five gifted
over there. Oh my god. >> Let me >> two gifted here
tonight. Three gifted tonight. Signal big supporter here. I think
Signal Signal is in our all-time highest. Not quite, but he has
been. >> Go ahead and call, you know, someone that I can
always call. You know what I'm saying? >> Let's see if
they are up. >> The wireless customer you are calling is
not available. Please try again later. >> You don't know
that guy. >> I think that's a blocked number. I think that's
a person. That's a burned bridge. Whoever he just called, that's
a burned bridge, right? Like that's somebody who blocked his
number and is like, I want to talk to you. Oh, >> man.
I I mean, am I getting blocked? I mean, who is this?
>> No, it's the wrong number. Maybe it's
Uh,
wrong number. Maybe he just dialed a fake number. >> The
wireless customer you are calling is not available. Please try
again later.
>> okay. Hold on. Yeah, it's Shuy apparently. But I will
say I will say that's also the response you get. I think if you're
on D and D, if you're in like harsh D and D on your phone, like
do not disturb. I think you can sometimes get that message. Like
people who call you will get that message. You >> tip one.
I know where you won't be screening. And that's
W squeeze.
>> Wait, Shuy, like why did you uh like block me, man?
What the [__] is wrong with you? I mean I I I mean,
you probably didn't block me, but you probably just busy with
Zena, you know. Let me try Discord. No way he blocked me, man.
No, he didn't. His phone is just on DND or something, man. Call
Nick. I don't have his uh number, man. You know what I'm saying?
Gosh, guys. I >> Bro, there's no way. How is Shuy not answering
the phone? Squeeze was like the content tonight. How is Shuy
not answering the phone? >> Come on, Shuy. Oh, you're you're
>> You said it. Busy with Zena. >> Just like I don't
know what you're doing. Is he even live? Like what, dude?
Like I told you that that I might want to, you know, do something.
Oh no, he's offline. Okay, we all know what he's doing. He is
>> How can I pre-watch this? I've been on stream since
before he started
>> Yeah, no need to really say anything. I didn't mean
to catch you, you know, at the wrong time, but um I'm streaming
right now. I'm live and I just wanted to contact you, man, because
I've had a long day and I wanted to know what your thoughts are
on the situation.
>> Oh, well, I mean, I just think it was funny as honestly.
>> Oh, really? >> Cuz they thought that they were
in the right. They thought the cops were going to be on their
side, and it was just funny, honestly. >> Well, they did.
>> Dude, I don't I I need an explanation from their side
of what they thought was going to happen. I need to talk I'll
talk to Legacy of Princess as soon as I can because
>> I need to know what they thought. >> Them Chicken
Andy they're riding on this idea that
>> you up by pressing charges. Don't look at what we did.
Don't look at how we are. Don't sure we signaled out to the chat.
Yeah, call the cops. Ignore all of that. He betrayed the code
and pressed charges.
Yeah,
I
>> even though all of the content going in and out of that
house has been calling the cops, pressing charges, filing lawsuits,
why is it this is the only I've seen get like audio torture for
>> you see anybody press M, you see anybody, to be fair,
Chicken wasn't living there before. >> Yeah. I also don't
think he would try that on Zena, MC, or anybody else. Well, he
wouldn't do it on Zena, but he might do it to Mark. I could see
him doing it to Mark. You know, >> I think they're just
trying this kid. >> They might just be trying. I mean,
yeah, he seems soft. >> Actually, steal from me and they
took my, you know, uh, GPU. So, >> Zezy, this is homophobia.
Just so you're aware, I told Zezy that Legacy's in prison. Zezy
said, "Oh, he'll enjoy it there." That's homophobia. Okay, you
can't say that because he's gay. He'll enjoy it there. What the
[__] is that? >> No, I say it because I know
his ass is not gay. Okay, maybe that's what Zezy is saying, too.
>> Nobody gets drunk and
and then straight. Like, oh, when I drink, I just want like,
okay, you straight, >> dude. I Okay, well, I don't think
he is, but I don't think he's straight. I just think he's uh
egen.
I'm just looking.
>> Yes. Fake gay to disarm women.
>> The way that men will be like >> playbook. Yeah,
>> men will be like, "Oh, I'm a
It is totally the Dylan Burns playbook. It's up. >> I think
it would have been funny low key. I mean, you people can call
me federal snitch, whatever. I don't really care. But um
>> Goon is not in >> Adriana. Adriiana was looking
into pressing charges on you. I think it would have been funny
if you like looked into pressing charges.
>> Oh, because apparently he took some of hers. I think
she was talking about dishes or something. >> She was saying
something in the house. It's like stupid and there's nothing.
There's nothing there. Yeah, he like took some dishes of hers.
I don't He probably threw it out or something >> on her
for vandalism. It would have been funny. You could have got the
whole house arrested and then stayed in it by
>> I don't know about that. But the thing is I um the reason
that I pressed charges was because that was actually stolen and
I actually wanted it. Hold up. My tires sound weird. >> Did
Did somebody deflate my tires, man?
My tires sound really odd. Uh they were kind of vandalizing his
drew on his car. >> No, I'm still here. >> I don't
know what happened. I saw
>> They drew on his car, right? That he owed money or whatever.
>> Remember, but I'm saying they might have drained his
tire here in the neighborhood. But the thing is I like have to
leave. Not because like I'm getting asked to leave because I
legally can stay here because I have legal rights, but because
of something else um that I can't really disclose. You know what
I'm saying? >> But like that's another topic that I can't
talk about. But um you know, oh god, I missed this car, man.
Holy [__] Um also, I just wanted to say that um you
know, how is the boat going? Like how how close are they to finishing
the uh the boat, man? >> Well, they're still in South Carolina.
Why you want to join the boat? >> I mean, I was thinking
of doing it, but like I just want to stream, man. So, if you
let me stream, I'll join. >> Okay. Well, maybe, >> dude,
it'll raise your your viewership 100%. I guarantee you that.
This is where Prawn and Legacy are. Okay, this is what happened.
>> Legacy still does not have shoes on. That That [__]
has That [__] is a
>> Hold on. That makes it so much better that she pointed
it out earlier in the stream, too. You think Legacy went to sho
went to went to jail barefoot
>> They probably they probably asked, "Do you want to grab
shoes?" And he's like, "I don't have any." Literally can't imagine
anything more disgusting than going to like prison without shoes
on. >> They will give you socks and shoes.
>> Okay. Yeah, probably.
>> I think they because you're not allowed to have like
laces or anything like that. So, they'll I think they generally
give inmates the vans slippers those things. Yeah. >> Regardless
of me even talking about that,
you said you have a court order. >> Oh [__]
I did forget about that.
Well, he said he was going to drop the
>> I am always cold, but that's because I'm iron deficient
and anemic. >> Decided to go on the boat, but I'm confused
because last time I checked, you know, the the the state was
actually pressing the charges. So, I'm not, you know, too sure
if it's him pressing the charges or or what's going on. Um, so
I'd have to maybe talk to him about
>> Are you allowed to speak? Oh, you're not allowed to
speak with him, huh? I mean, I'm allowed to talk to him, but
I'm not allowed to see him. I think
>> Why don't you Why don't we actually put him on the phone
right now? >> Oh, just to be clear, Plant Dad is saying
in the Discord that Merc called the cops. We did pull the merk
logs. Okay, earlier we pulled the merk logs. I don't know that
we know that she called the cops. Merc on some bad empanada.
She would totally say she called the cops if she didn't call
the cops. She would totally do that. Okay. >> Yeah, but
also remember the the good cop came up. He's like, "This might
have to do with Darius." I I understand he has >> It didn't
have to do with Darius. >> This had nothing to do with
Darius, but the cop was prepared and aware of Darius in the house.
>> Oh, I'm aware he has haters.
>> I've been We've been told about the haters. The haters
are on file.
>> Yeah. So, she said twice, "I'm calling the police. I
called the police. Call the cops." She was telling Squeeze to
call the cops. I'm calling the cops. Squeeze, you're an idiot.
I called the police. And then Darius must have said something
to her and he said she said mold harder.
>> Jeez. Jeez.
>> Well, he I think he's on do not disturb. >> is
he awake? >> Oh, I think he's live. So, I could try asking
in his chat. >> I mean, okay. I mean, he's live and awake
or what?
>> Is he live and awake?
>> Okay. Well, I mean, let's get him on the phone. I mean,
you can do that. That would be great. >> Yeah, let me let
me ask him. >> Okay. I can make a group chat on
>> Accelerating, I read your comment, man. Uh, that's true.
>> No, it's a bond condition. Uh, >> now question.
>> Now question. >> Question. Because everything
that you have on film from this incident, this guy is standing
in front of the cops. He does decide he wants to press charges.
The cops starts telling him, they exchange back and forth. Chicken
Andy comes over and is like, "What if you want can he like >> so
drop? >> Remove the charges now cuz you should remove the
charges now." >> And so that's on camera, >> right?
And then afterwards you see him just
like terrorize him in the house. He's getting
this is like retaliation from the housemates. >> Yeah.
Are you >> Can he can go Karen on all of them. >> I
don't I don't think there's any >> I don't think he will,
but he could. No, I don't think there's I doubt there's anything
you could actually do there. >> Like that would be one
of those things where there's probably a law that technically
but they would have to like get they'd have to get a call. They'd
have to like tell him to stop and then they'd have to come back
another time or some [__] Like I don't I don't say
it's like illegal. Like if you're you're trying to imply that
they're like intimidating him to drop charges, right? >> Uh
well, first of all, I'm trying to imply that the two people that
are holding it are not the only two people involved in stealing
it. Chicken Andy did talk about it,
right? He said, "Repace that with a banana." He was in on it.
>> But he didn't get arrested. And him not getting arrested
contributed to trying to pressure this dude to drop charges.
>> Sure. I don't know if you're just You're just saying
he probably has a way to go after Chicken Andy if he wants to.
>> Yeah. I would say
I don't know. The cops seem to say we did the two guys. That
was their like >> if if Adriana Lee is going to theory
craft suing him in return for lost >> Yeah, true. True.
>> I'm a theory craft this way.
>> Goofy ass chicken ass. >> It's got to be It's
got to be some kind of I don't know if you can do this for things
that are like misdemeanor. It's got to be some kind of like weird
thing to just be standing there watching somebody commit a crime
against someone,
>> No, he didn't just watch. He uh he took >> He
did say Yeah, he had a suggestion. That's true. So much like
just so much stuff, man. Seriously, this is
Sounds good. >> Oh, hello. >> Yeah. Yeah, I'm just
in his chat trying to tell him if I can get him on a call. >> All
right, sounds good. Dude, I really did not expect this to happen
today. I just expected to come and just maybe like get pressed
a little bit. >> Oh, it would have been so funny if you
said something as he walked away, bro. The the long-haired dude.
>> I know, but I I was trying to be civil and, you know,
courageous, you know. I mean, it just it just would have honestly
been hilarious.
>> I see. >> Yeah, private hop. Conspiracy. I would
get his chicken out on conspiracy and then retaliation and intimidating
the
or the victim. >> Let me text cowboy
>> Please, please, please, Mark, please. >> What
is M saying there? Did you make a group chat? Can you make a
three-way call? Or I guess I can >> I mean, I can make
a three-way call.
>> I mean, >> we had 3 hours 51. I'm going to actually
go to his bot again. I'm on his live right now, but 3 hours 51.
3 hours 51. We might be able to see what was on the bot here.
>> Seriously, it was overwhelming. >> It just would
have honestly been
>> All right, hold on. >> We'll see if we can see
what she says in the chat here.
>> Give it a second. >> Let me text cowboy >> Mark.
Mark's with him. MK Merc.
>> Uh, well, I don't see MK typing in the chat. Must got
deleted. >> Mark, please.
>> Please, Mark, please. Please, >> please don't.
>> Did you make a group chat? Can you make a three-way
call or I guess I can >> I mean, I can make a three-way
call.
>> I mean, I have I have his Discord. I have his Discord.
Let's see. I actually Oh, there we go. There we go. >> One
second. >> Hi. I'm just going to text Hi. >> Oh,
the is whack again. We should make it clear >> saying stuff
like that. >> I'm just Let me >> Oh, wait. Hold on.
>> Let me just have fun on stream. >> MC did say
drop the lure now. He's got a warrant for his arrest. Oh, she's
saying some about Darius. Oh, I got to go find it now. Hold on.
Wait, there's like better chat logs than this site. >> I
will say like a million crazy things on stream and then people
will latch on to the one thing that sounds like a little bit
sane. I literally said that they should alert the FBI that Chicken
Andy is one of the furries that they've been looking into for
domestic terrorism. Got him. Squeeze. We're looking for >> still
very valid though. Very, very
>> Perk off the perk.
These logs. Wait, what?
Why did this >> What are we looking up now? Oh, like what
she typed in here.
>> Yeah, hold on. This is where we're looking. Yes, we're
looking for this.
This right here. >> Everybody in chat that says a chicken
isn't a furry, red flag.
If you're correcting me on what is the f red
flag, >> she's uh she's in here. She's typing like a lot
of the night. Hold on. When was this here?
It's got a warrant. Turn in Darius for the reward. Lol.
That's that's where that's where Squeeze starts shaking his head.
No, no, no, no, no. >> Dream, man. So much fun. >> All
right. I'm glad you're having fun. >> Is that why he was
locked in his room
>> for Darius? I think that's why Darius Darius wanted
no part of this as far as I can tell. Darius did not want to
be out there. Darius doesn't want >> What is she talking
about?
>> Um I don't know. He's got a warrant for his arrest.
Apparently there's a different warrant out for Darius's arrest.
I Oh, was that supposed to be secret? Oh,
does Darius is Darius supposed to be getting arrested? >> Just
go back to the video. Don't talk about it. >> Don't talk
about it. Okay. I have been invited multiple times to go on that
vote and I lowkey want to under certain certain circumstances.
Um but I'm not sure what the situation is between. >> Well,
I don't know what for guys. I >> me and you like um like
legalitywise
legal wise. >> I'm not either. All I know is that when
me and Merc called, we called the
>> Oh,
wait. I do think this is correct. Matrix user. Wasn't this the
case that he went to Canada? >> I don't know if he if it's
real or not. So, I feel like
I'm just going to time people out
>> for speculating. >> Oh, well. >> Well, all
right. >> We said, "Listen, how does this >> that
is why Squeeze left when Darius told him to?"
>> It sounds like they don't want to get Darius in trouble.
>> [__] do this [__] Like, we didn't
ask for this. They said, "As long as
uh they're like you can come to me and I
as long as I'm not the one calling the police to get rid of you,
then
>> she said it's fine, but
uh you I can go to you or you can come to me and if I don't do
anything, it's fine." So, according to them, it doesn't matter.
It's not like the state's going to come in and be like, "You
guys can't be around each other." They don't give a [__]
And I don't call the police. >> I am not going to call
the police on >> Also, we're not in Texas. >> Also,
yeah, we're notic.
It doesn't matter what the
I'm the only one who can do this because the judge did the protective
order against
>> really well. Did you debate that? Did you like the video?
Going back to farming is >> I told them that I was not
gay. I would not stay as witness and I didn't want a protective
order and they they said it's a judge. >> The judge did
it. >> Got it. >> I can do about it. >> Okay.
Interesting.
Um >> I dropped charges like the next day after that [__]
So I don't give a [__] about either. I have no problem
with you at all, dude. I I I look forward I hope we can hang
out again at some point. I saw you at the bar that one time on
Sixth Street and I think that was [__] I was trying
to extend an olive >> Man, I I feel the same towards you.
I feel like you've made a great come up. I feel like you are
an entertaining guy, fun dude, you know, respectable dude. So,
you know, I would love to make content with you as well. Just
have to follow the law, man. And I'll read over my, you know,
bond conditions and uh, you know, I >> What is this? How
human beings talk >> that one time on Six Street and I
think that was I was trying to extend an olive >> Man,
I I feel the same towards you. I feel like you >> I feel
like zoomers are like psychopaths. Like they're actually just
brainbroken psychopaths who like barely mimic human behavior
sometimes. Like yeah bro I saw you at a bar one time. I really
respect what you do. Made a great come up. I feel like you are
an entertaining guy, fun dude, you know, respectable dude. So
you know I would love to make content with you as well. Just
have to follow the law, man. And I'll read over my, you know,
bond conditions. And uh >> it's not even Zoomers. This
might be under Zoomer already. You know, I don't know if weird
like trying to mimic how humans would talk and just like failing
like just like there's something off like I think he's like an
alien somehow. >> You if if you're the one that that is
pressing the charges or the state is cuz I'm I'm not sure. >> Yeah,
I don't think the state was pressing charges against you. I think
the state was only pressing charges against Darius. >> Is
this Zeus on the phone? Cuz I think what Squeeze talked about
earlier in the night was getting Zeus to drop the charges against
him. But I don't know if Zeus has charges against him. Okay.
It is Zeus. >> No. No. I No. I I talked to my lawyer. The
state is >> Okay. So, definitely Squeeze does not think
Zeus is like a clean, respectable content creator. And that I
say that as somebody who thinks Zeus is funny >> pressing
charges against me. Yeah. So, I guess it's the state. >> Oh,
that's really weird. That's That's definitely nothing. That's
not me. I don't know why they're doing that. >> Okay. Well,
I mean, I believe you because the the state the they literally
said that the state is doing it. So, um, it's fine. >> That's
really strange because the only reason the state got involved
was because Merk and Darius each other. So, the state came in
and said that was like domestic abuse or some [__]
>> like literally or like a you know
>> literally they each other.
>> Oh man, I don't want to think about that. But um hey
man, >> romantic relationship and smashing and >> the
state came in and said this is domestic abuse cuz he smashed
that egg that one egg on himself and then poured it on her. >> Right.
Right. >> Um that was domestic. So that was from what I
understood from the council I talked to that was the only state
um the only thing the state was taking over was that aspect of
it. As far as your name was concerned, there was no state charges
that I would I could I dropped everything that >> I don't
know. That's something going on stream. Okay. >> The only
thing we couldn't drop was the domestic thing. The state took
that. >> Yeah. Yeah. No, I wasn't
>> I wasn't part of any >> Squeeze was trying to
MC. [__] on MC. Despite being Darius's boy to be
fair, Squeeze is trying to on everybody at all times. Okay. But
I don't I don't know if I've seen that happen that Squeeze was
trying to hit on Merc. Zeus was trying to hit on Mur >> and
that domestic stuff. But either way, um uh yeah, I'll just go
over the the condition. And I mean, from what I've heard, I should
be good to go. You know, I' I'd like I said, I feel like it would
be great content to hang out on the >> Um but at the same
time, I would like to stream. So, I also have to talk to Shuy
about that. But
>> if says you can stream, I'm not I'm not giving you
>> What? Go ahead. >> No, no, no, wait, wait. So,
what I was gonna say is, uh, so basically Zeus has been under
like the rule that when I'm live, what's up, man? He's not live.
And I'm just going to ask Zeus, how often would you say that
you've been able to go live? >> Mhm. Yeah. >> Uh,
every day. I mean, I'm like I go live every day regardless.
>> And I would, too. I just need my phone fixed by
not going live. It's just because his phone's [__]
>> Okay. So, I mean, >> how about you?
I mean, just the same rules as them, bro. Like, you can go live
when I'm not live, but >> And still get paid when you're
not live. >> Am I >> So, you can't be live on Chuvy's
boat when he's live. Uh, I think Zena wasn't Zena live when Chuy
was live. >> I think they I Doesn't he mean to like leech
off his community?
Well, yeah, that's what I think that's what Shuy saying is like
don't go and leech my viewers while I'm live on my paying for
which is like fair I guess. >> I I assumed he meant you
won't be able to leech off my viewers.
>> like when I'm live, they're obviously going to watch
me, but if I'm not live, you go live and they'll go watch you.
>> Oh, maybe that's what he means. >> Are you Are
you partnered yet or >> am I part? >> Yes, Zeus,
I am. Uh, I think I'm
>> This is what we can do. just to make >> Oh, no.
It is what you're saying. That's >> in the morning we all
work out and we drink pre-workout and [__] and I
usually in the morning I've been pulling like 600 viewers, dude.
So, instead of me streaming since you actually will make [__]
money and Cowboys phone is [__] we'll just have you
stream in the morning. >> Um, instead of me that way, you
know, you can make some [__] instead of just no money.
Yeah,
>> this is
>> I can literally tell you like trying to have a phone
call off my phone with shitty is like impossible.
>> hold up. I'm being like stalked right now. Uh I'm going
to check out what's going on cuz I'm I'm being like stalked by
someone. Like someone's like I don't know. They're like signaling
>> like what's going on here, man? Hold up. >> Okay.
You want to talk, >> bro? You told your stream I need a
place to stay. >> [__] is that? I I >> was
getting stalked. >> They know you got nowhere to go. >> No,
we can talk. >> How awesome would it be if it is Chicken
Andy in like a souped-up Civic and he like rolls down his his
windows and it's just music blaring. It's his again his theme
song.
>> He's just here and Chicken Andy in a monster truck.
>> Oh boy. >> Okay, that's fine. We're I'm all good.
Um yeah, so you said that I could like be um
>> when when you're live and I'm not live. We've got what
do we have for the rest of the night? We've got We've got the
techone video.
>> There's a techone video. >> There's a new techone
video where he is probably going to
>> reiterate his retirement. I would imagine going to reiterate
his
>> I love when someone's retirement takes 10 videos. >> When
Judy is lying. >> Yeah. What will I get? >> Not lie.
>> Then we split his KP three ways. Technically Zeus keeps
saying he wants none, but I still have it offered. Yeah, but
you understand that if I don't finish the journey, I'm not going
to get paid because obviously
I'm not going to get money if I quit. And I'm planning to go
there just to hang around and not really finish the journey,
you know? Um, so yeah, man. >> okay. So, you want to go
there
and just for like a few days,
>> Well, then why would I
>> That's what I'm saying. I don't want you to split the
KBP. I'm saying that if I stream, I'll be able to make money
and then I could entertain and make money at the same time and
be a character on the >> That That's between you and Shu.
>> That's what I'm asking you, Shu. I mean, I don't have
to, but I mean, I would like to visit,
but fairly get paid, you >> I mean,
venture that I am proposing and allowing you to become a part
of, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> You don't sound
too sure. Right. Or >> Yeah. I mean, don't I mean, I know
what you're trying to tell me, man. You're trying to like manipulate.
>> Hey guys,
>> can you stop bullying my friend Teone? He's really hurt
by all the things you've been saying about him.
>> All right, >> it's all good, man. Snorl, are you
are you actually friends with Techone? >> that's Tone.
>> That's rough, buddy. >> That's a rough one. >> Is
Snorl a real person or is that a Tactone alt? Because >> I
do feel like Tone is the type of dude that if you say his name,
he'll just >> If I put his name in the title, he might
show up. Yeah, that is absolutely true. entirely possible. Do
you agree that that is like is that not true? >> I mean,
I guarantee you I could, you know, make other content, but I
was interested in doing this. >> I'm techone. See, >> I
mean, I could do other >> content you didn't watch. Uh,
Squeeze gets called get the cops called by Shuy and left at a
gas station. Wait, what is this? Why' you Why is this a YouTube
>> Okay, stay online. I sent you over to Westampton police
dispatcher. >> All right.
>> Oh, so this is the history between him and so keep blaming
things on me. Wait,
>> why did Squeeze get the cops called on him? This two
weeks ago
reports that he's trying to get someone removed from the car.
>> All right, thank you. Hello, Sean.
>> Wait, why? Cuz he wouldn't leave the
Wait, why was he Are they driving to Florida from like Are they
driving to Florida from where?
Austin.
That's kind of >> That's what I'm saying, Private Huff.
These people love the cops. They've been calling the cops for
months. >> No, Shuy loves the cops. Shuy will always press
charges. >> Yeah, but that's what I'm saying. Cuz before
you were saying this is a rule with IRL. You don't get the cops
involved. No. All these people have been getting the cops involved.
>> Is a snitch made Okay. Sn Yeah, Shivy snitches all the
time. Shiv
built I understand why he's a snitch. >> Yeah, he built
like a snitch. >> Yeah. Um, just one of the people that
I was riding on a road trip with. >> All right. Just so
you know them. Is this a friend? >> Yeah. Yeah, I know
him.
>> Okay. Do me a favor, Sean, and just stay on the phone
for me. Okay. I'm going to get the unit started out there. >> All right.
Thank you. It's an unsafe location if you can hear me. He's trying
to drop me off in the middle of the woods in an unsafe location.
So, I asked him to kindly drop me off at a civilized area, but
he's not doing that. >> Try to mama [__] him.
I'm willing to get out as long as it's in a safe location, >> Hi,
Sean. You still there? >> Yeah, I'm still here. >> All right.
I got my officers. They're on the way right now. What type of
car do you drive? >> Um, a Ford Eine, a white van.
>> Sir, if you can hear me, he's trying to drop me off
in the middle of basically nowhere. I asked him kindly to drop
me off at a civilized area, >> but he's not doing that.
>> Um, I'm willing to get out as long as it's in >> Yeah.
Not in the Not in the middle of the highway, right? Like, let
me get out at a gas station or something. I think he means >> Yeah,
he doesn't mean a civilized area. >> Civilized. They're
in America. Okay. Drop them off in another country. Once they
get to Canada, he'll get out of the car. Okay. >> A safe
area,
but it's in the middle of nowhere. So, >> I understand,
sir. I'm going to have some officers come over there and try
to sort the situation out. >> Okay. Nope. >> All
right. So, they call the cops. Cops do end up showing up. >> We're
designated safe space. >> Okay. So, how you guys know each
other? >> Uh, well, we were friends, but apparently he
doesn't like me anymore.
He said designated safe space. >> Designated safe spot.
I don't know. He just means somewhere like a gas station or something.
>> Somewhere with a
non-binary bathroom. Like what does that >> Designated
safe space.
Um, so yeah, the cops I'm guessing this is just weird. It's like
I he used to be my friend, but I guess he doesn't like me anymore.
>> So I mean look, if you go down here, this is Oxville.
be a right like half half a mile down the road is is a gas station.
>> All right. Well, >> I'll follow you if you want.
>> I mean, I'm allowed to tell anyone to leave my vehicle
at any time, right? Or no. Okay. Well, I would just like him
to >> Okay. So, >> I I just don't I don't owe him
that luxury of doing that for personal
>> This is like uh super dickish, though. I mean, you you
hate some dude. He's been doing content with you. You drop him
off at a [__] gas station. You drop him off in the
woods. >> What was that? >> He wants you to leave.
Is this is this car in your name? >> Although I will say
they're all like the kind of person where it's like if you don't
get them out when you can get them out, then you don't know.
Like you drive to the gas station, then they're like, "No, I
don't want to get out here now." >> So, I do maybe understand
how it's like, "Oh, the cops are here. Go get in the cop car.
Cop will drive you there." >> They're going to [__]
with you for as much as you let them. >> Yeah. Yeah. No,
I I do get it that like this might just be how you have to deal
with it after a while, right? It's like Yeah. You know what?
Yeah. after how he acted with Darius. It's like, you know what?
You can go get in that cop car.
>> I'm not sure if it's in his name or not. >> I'm
asking him. >> It's in my name. >> It's in my name.
Sorry. >> Did he just This mother I'm not sure if it's
in my name or not. I think you know if your name is on Chu's
car.
What the do you mean? >> Um like I'm kind of in the middle
of nowhere, though. I'm trying to get to a designated safe space.
Like >> what is a designated safe space? I tell you what,
I'll I'll put you in the back of my car. >> Shuy ain't
know either. Okay. Shuy also got no idea what a designated safe
space is taking to the gas station.
>> I'm I'm recording body camera. I just don't allow like
recording car uh cameras in my car just in case you're worried
about that. Like I am recording as well. >> Okay. Well,
I'm a live streamer. I'm not doing this just because >> that's
I'm just saying in the backseat of my car. There's no there's
no streaming. There's no recording. >> Okay. Sure. I'll
turn if you want to like alleviate any problem. I'll give you
a ride. >> I appreciate that. I would appreciate that.
I have a suitcase and a backpack. That's fine. All right. Okay,
cool. Let me just grab my stuff. >> Designated safe space,
by the way. >> He's not good for it now. Okay, cool. Should
be gets bounced.
>> Uh I think there's uh Hold on. I should wait till that
clip until I'm like >> should actually click through. Shy
gets
>> He eventually does get out. >> All set.
>> you're all set. And they get out of there. Okay, I should
just click to the end to make sure we don't miss anything. All
right, we're back to this guy. >> Watch for a little bit
longer. We'll see what's up here. Then we're going to check out
the STO video. >> A small amount of your KCIP while you're
on the boat. >> Oh my goodness.
>> Could you imagine? >> They call you Shuy Pac.
>> When he's on the boat and he's like, "The boat's not
in your name. Get off." I would not get on this guy's boat. Out
of here.
>> Drive You'll drive him out to like um one of the cell
towers or like one of the buoys out in the middle of the water.
Listen, I just I'm allowed to get you off of my boat. Okay. I
don't have safe here. Look safe here, buddy. >> Yeah, this
is a design. We designated the safe space for you. Okay. >> Yeah,
I mean that's
>> What do you mean 1%? Dude, >> are you saying you
want 1% of your KBB while you're on the boat?
>> no, bro. You're not getting any percentage on my KPB,
man. I'm sorry, man. That's not going to happen.
>> I'll go on the boat if I could just be on the boat and
just hang around there. And if you don't think that's >> the
boat, listen, the boat is going to protect is going to present
to you opportunities to have content and build higher viewers,
whereas if you were on land, you wouldn't have as many opport
>> No, that's not true. I could I could do a lot of things
that I've thought of, but I haven't done. So, you're wrong about
that, man. >> No, I just want to say on the boat, there's
a chance >> Sorry, Flamster's asking chat, who's in jail?
It's uh
Prawn and and Legacy are spending the night in jail tonight,
guys. Okay, this is this is what's up. This is what's happening.
It's very It's not really unfortunate. Okay, you go back a little
bit in the stream, you can see exactly how it happened. Ron ended
up in jail. He absolutely did. Yes, that's why it's in the title.
>> Aka way more chances for good high viewer uh content,
aka a lot more chances for you to make money. All right. Potentially
more money than you would make if you were not on the boat. I'm
not asking for a lot. I'm asking I haven't even told you how
much. >> Okay. will tell me how much.
>> Just 10%. >> Dude trying to make his money >> of
my KP.
>> It's crazy. >> That's it. 10%. >> Dude,
that's crazy, man. I'm not I mean, >> And you can you can
stream the boat and profit off of it. >> Oh my god, bro.
Like, why do you do this, man? Bro, let me just go on the boat
without any sort of crazy deal. >> I didn't give anybody
else a deal like that, bro. That's already special enough. So,
if you don't want to take that, that's fine, >> guys. Is
Is it Is it worth it?
guys. Yes or no? Is it worth it? I mean, that's just
>> Yeah, it's worth it. >> I mean, I'm having a lot
of >> like a long con.
>> Shu is going to take a percentage and then once he gets
how much this guy owes him rent, he's going to give it back to
>> Uh, that would make no sense just because Shuy hates
Darius. True. But, but, you know, in a general sense, it could
be, hey, it could be something along those lines. Okay, maybe
he'll use it to pay for his >> that they want to see me
on the boat. And then a lot of people say that they don't want
to see me on the boat. So, I'm kind of like in the middle here.
And at the end of the day, it's up to what I actually want to
do. But you see, it's like a mix of no and yes,
I'm not the best. >> All right, cowboy. Definitely I should
probably listen to you because you got you're the fastest streamer
that ever got KP. So, yeah, I should probably listen to you.
>> Is that true? If it was me, I would come on the boat
and I would legitimately
not the way that you're talking about.
>> I'm about to opt out of this, guys. We have two options
for the rest of the night and I'm actually going to put it to
a poll and we'll let the chat decide. Okay. Two options. One
of two. I'm either going to pull up Pisco's
reading of the indictment of Comey because Pisco obviously has
gone back and forth with Rob and
Constantly, right? So, I might pull up his thing uh his reading
of that >> or don't do three or
one of the two. We'll watch Tees apparently. I don't even know
if this is like his final
but I think those are the two things I've got. I might have other
stuff in the docket. I'm just not I don't really have that much
else in the docket. Oh, there's there is Halfbaked with Auggie.
Nicholas Dioro, Turkey Tom, Auggie. >> Did they have Rob's
media on? >> I don't think so. >> Is this They didn't
do Halfbaked with him this time. >> I thought they said
he was going to be >> I thought he was supposed to be on,
but
>> they out.
>> I Well, I just don't think they had him on this time.
>> Oh, are they going to wait until it's no longer like
a hot topic and be like, "No, see, we did talk to him." when
everyone's going under scrutiny for his video, now is the time
to not have him on. That doesn't make sense.
>> Uh maybe they just don't want none of that smoke, you
know?
>> Uh please be nice to Tech. I'm going to be really freaking
upset. Wait, Snorl, you're not literally friends with Tech. You're
not like the guy I talked to before, are you? Let me uh let me
go ahead and create a poll here. Seems like we got a lot of people
doing the Pisco Comey thing, which is a little surprising to
me that Tech is not winning out at all. I'm I voted three. >> Even
if we gave all of the votes to Techone, which by law were required
to, we still couldn't actually make up the difference. It's it's
it's wild. I don't I don't even That's wild to me.
>> You'd never expect.
>> Do you see how many people are saying do it, take it?
I think that's a great, >> bro. Do you also see how many
people are saying no, don't do it. >> There's a lot. >> I
think majority are saying yes. I mean, if you want to run a poll,
you can run a poll. I would do it, but I would I would maybe
maybe >> I thought we only watch Technone ironically. We
do watch Techone ironically, but
this is crazy. >> You stream while Look, I I just got to
give it a bug squeeze. If you stream on this boat while Shu is
live, you're not going to get a lot of viewers.
>> Okay, then then then,
bro, I just listen. I just wanted to be a special guest. That's
it. If not, then it's fine. We can talk about it later, man.
>> I feel bad.
>> No, I mean, you definitely can. We'll No, no, no. Shuy,
we'll talk about it later. I'll I'll I'll make my decision soon,
okay? You know, I I know what your proposal is and you know,
I'll make my decision, okay? So,